Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Während man in den 80ern von der Bundespest für die Benutzung von Modems noch vor Gericht gestellt wurde, ist der Anschluss der kleinen Pfeiffer heute schon Standard. Internetcomputer haben zwar manchmal immer noch kein Add-on auf der Tastatur, aber ohne Modem werden die Maschinen auch nicht mehr ausgeliefert. Jeder will auf die Datenautobahn und das möglichst schnell. Waren früher Akustikkoppler die Inkarnation des Fortschritts, sind heute analoge Modems schon langsam Auslaufware. ISDN muss es schon sein, wenn es rauschen soll, doch ist damit das Ende der Fahnenstange noch lange nicht erreicht. Und mit ADSL steht der nächste Gebührenoverkill schon vor der Tür. Chaosradio erklärt Begriffe und Protokolle und wünscht eine gute Datenreise.
Danke fürs Zuschauen. Ich bin.
Schon sehr gespannt, was das ist. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt, was das ist. Eigentlich jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, diesmal am ersten im Monat, wie das so schön ist mit den Ausnahmen. Können wir kurz einen Mikrocheck haben, ob alle da sind? Ach so, warte mal für Wau, dann müssen wir dann das Mikro anmachen, damit ihr euch das wieder teilt. Warte mal, probieren wir gleich. Geht's schon? Hallo, der Mike. Na, da müssen wir gleich noch mal ein bisschen nachwägeln. Mal noch mal.
Hallo, der Mike.
Super.
Marsmusik kommt von Agent Me und mehr zum Thema gibt's gleich. Ach so, und hier ist auch noch Johnny. Das sind Live-Aufnahmen von Agent Me. Das ist live eingespielt und jetzt für euch hier reproduziert. Natürlich digital, wie sich das für Chaos Radio gehört. Gehen wir ein bisschen tiefer aufs Thema ein oder gibt es vorher noch ein paar Sachen, die wir abhaken sollten, vor allem kurz Info?
Na ja, also wir können ja vielleicht erst mal so zu den generellen Dingen sagen. Demnächst ist wieder CeBIT.
Wir machen heute 40 Seiten Special.
Wir erzählen euch heute alles, was ihr auf der CeBIT sehen werdet. Nein.
Ich hab neulich mit jemandem gesprochen, der ganz verzweifelt war, weil ich gesagt hab, ich fahr nicht zur CeBIT. Der konnte das überhaupt nicht verstehen.
Kann ich auch nicht verstehen. Fass mich hin?
Spaß haben.
Mich mit lauter Handy-Benutzern durch enge, verschwitzte Gänge quetschen und das, was ich hier an dem Tisch hab.
Nein, man macht natürlich Live-Hackings und versucht, alle Pressekonferenzen abzuräumen.
Und abends Parties.
Ach, die sagen umwunden CeBIT-Parties.
Genau.
Hab ich noch keiner erlebt, wahrscheinlich war ich immer auf dem falschen.
Eine Information kann man noch mal kommunizieren, es ging um die Frage, ob der CCC denn wieder irgendwie mit einem Stand vertreten sein wird. Die Antwort ist nein. Das schenken wir uns dieses Jahr. Aber wir sind natürlich wieder am Dienstag da, am Chaos-Dienstag. Und wir werden uns auch, wie das in unserer Tradition ist, am Dienstag um 16 Uhr irgendwo auf der CeBIT treffen. Wir sagen aber noch nicht wo. Das werden wir dann irgendwie rechtzeitig genug noch über das Chaos-Update rausschicken.
Oder ihr liest es einfach unseren Seiten nach. Genau.
Also wenn ihr auf der CeBIT seid, auf jeden Fall irgendwie was an irgendeinem Terminal, die ja massig rumstehen, mal kurz auf www.ccc.de checken, was dann am Dienstag genau passiert. Da werdet ihr dann Details erfahren. Wolltest du noch was zum Sommer sagen?
Na ja, also ich kann da noch nicht so viel zu sagen.
Super.
Wir haben da, es gibt da eine Sommerveranstaltung. Aber dazu zu CeBIT mehr.
Also sagt nicht hinterher, wir hätten es euch nicht rechtzeitig gesagt. Es gibt eine Sommerveranstaltung.
Ihr habt es hier zuerst erfahren.
Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt von irgendwelchen Sommerveranstaltungen lest, wir waren die ersten. Es wird natürlich eine spezielle Sommerveranstaltung geben. Da werdet ihr in dieser Sendung und natürlich auch über die Webseiten des Chaos Computer Clubs weiter informiert werden. Es gibt unter anderem übrigens auch einen neuen Chat bei Fritz, den wir gerade testen. Also der Web-Chat, der ist unter www.fritz.de slash speakers und dann findet man den V-Chat, da kann man mal ein bisschen rum experimentieren. Das ist eine sehr kleine Schrift, aber auf jeden Fall funktioniert es sehr viel schneller als der, den wir vorher hatten.
Echt? Ich denke, das ist jetzt ein Java.
Ja, trotzdem scheint es zu funktionieren. Und ansonsten gibt es wahrscheinlich auch einen Telnet-Chat?
Ja, der ist jetzt nicht mehr wirklich Telnet-Chat, der ist jetzt SSH-Chat.
Na gut, was heißt denn SSH-Chat?
Na ja, genau, geht nur noch über SSH, Secure Shell. Und irgendwie habe ich gehört, dass Leute mit komischen Betriebssystemen damit Probleme haben.
Also alles außer Linux oder was?
Also der Chat ist schon noch öffentlich. Man muss sich halt nur den Public Key runterladen vom FTP-Server auf BerlinCCC.de. Und mit dem Key kann man dann genauso am Chat teilnehmen wie vorher mit Telnet auch. Aber dadurch ist halt der Chat selber komplett verschlüsselt.
Das ist ja super. Also die Verschlüsselung ist natürlich prinzipiell erstmal gut, aber der Zugang ist nicht gerade der einfachste, oder?
Ja.
Also für die Leute, die vielleicht Sachen besprechen wollen, die nicht jeder mitkriegen soll, für die dann den?
Na ja, es ist ja nicht wirklich so, dass er nicht offen wäre. Es ist sozusagen eine gewisse Hürde ist zu nehmen.
Genau, Hürde ist ein gutes Wort.
Also man weiß zumindest von den Leuten, die drin sind, dass sie SSH konfiguriert haben.
Sie haben es geschafft.
Und ansonsten gibt es sicher auch im ERC wieder irgendeinen Kanal, der Chaosradio heißt oder ähnlich. Und wie gesagt, auf den Fritz Webpages natürlich auch das zur Kommunikation. Ansonsten kann man vielleicht auch gleich noch sagen, die E-Mail ist chaos.orb.de. Die Seiten vom CCC findet man unter www.ccc.de und ansonsten www.fritz.de. Und jetzt können wir langsam anfangen mit der Sendung. Jetzt lohnt es sich aber kaum noch, vor dem Fritz-Konzept direkt da einzusteigen. Wir hören einfach noch ein bisschen Musik und dann geht es richtig los. Der Oberbegriff unseres heutigen Themas hier im Chaos Radio lautet Netzzugangstechnologie.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Es ist 22.30 Uhr.
Ökosteuer. Der Bundestag hat die Gesetzesvorlage angenommen. Danach sollen zum 1. April die Benzin- und Energiepreise erhöht und die Beiträge zur Rentenversicherung gesenkt werden. Im Gesetz muss noch der Bundesrat zustimmen. Einspruch. Kurz vor der geplanten Hinrichtung des Deutsch-Amerikaners Lagran hat ein Berufungsgericht in den USA einen Aufschub verfügt. Der Bundesstaat Arizona kündigte sofort eine Gegenklage an. Das Todesurteil gegen Lagran wegen Raubmordes soll noch heute vollzogen werden. Bilanz. Bei der Deutschen Bahn sind 1998 die Umsätze und Erträge gesunken. Konzernchef Ludwig sagte, trotz der Unfälle in letzter Zeit sei die Bahn ein sicheres Verkehrsmittel. Vorstoß. Das Land Brandenburg will mit erweiterten Polizeibefugnissen gegen die Kriminalität vorgehen. Das Kabinett belichte eine Gesetzesänderung, die verdachtsunabhängige Kontrollen ermöglicht. Ehrung. Die in Berlin lebende 85-jährige Elisabeth Wurst erhielt den israelischen Titel Gerechte unter den Völkern. Sie hatte während der Nazi-Diktatur jüdischen Bürgern das Leben gerettet. Die Geschichte der Lili Wurst war die Grundlage für den Kinofilm Amy und Jaguar.
Sport.
Fußball in der Champions League führt Bayern München kurz vor Spielende gegen Kaiserslautern 2 zu 0. Wetter. Nachts 7 bis 5 Grad, am Tage gelegentlich Schauer 10 bis 14 Grad. Uns liegen zur Zeit keine Verkehrsmeldung vor, Skiz 5, gute Fahrt.
Wenn man wenigstens sagen könnte, dass wir beide tierisch gesoffen haben und deswegen so komische Stimmen haben, aber bei mir stimmt es nicht.
Soll ich mich jetzt outen oder was?
Ja, ich dachte du sagst jetzt was dazu. Na, jetzt wenn ja Baumgartner, was mit dem Tritts Kurzendvorst. Wie soll das anders sein? Musik, sag ich nochmal, kommt von Agent Me und das könnt ihr nicht kaufen, nein. Das muss man sich live angucken, wenn die beiden irgendwo mal wieder... Sagt man eigentlich spielen dann in dem Fall? Ja, spielen. Denn das ist live aufgenommen bei Konzerten und jetzt hier von einem digitalen Medium. Ich weigere mich, mein Name zu sagen. Das ist nicht mp3. Thema Chaosradio, sowas ähnliches, das stimmt. Das sind heute Netzzugangstechnologien. Was müssen wir uns darunter jetzt genau vorstellen? Reden wir jetzt darüber, was da kommt, was da war und warum immer noch so viele verschiedene Stecker auf der ganzen Welt in die Telefonleitung gehören, oder?
Ja, unter anderem, also was wir beleuchten wollen, sind all die Technologien, die eingesetzt werden, um jemandem Zugang zu einem Netz zu liefern. Wobei ich jetzt mal ganz offen lassen möchte am Anfang, um was für ein Netz es sich da handelt. Das heißt, wir gehen jetzt gleich mal auch ein bisschen auf die Herkunft der ganzen Geschichte an. Am Kern wollen wir natürlich da landen, was heute auch aktuell ist. Das heißt, wie bindet man sich eigentlich an über das Internet? Was sind eigentlich die konkreten Technologien, die man nun zum Einsatz bringen muss, damit eben diese Verbindung hergestellt wird? Und was können sie leisten? Grundsätzlich ist es halt das Problem der Datenübertragung. Also wenn man früher irgendwie Datenkommunikation betreiben wollte, und mit früher, meine ich jetzt mal 1999, also sagen wir mal so vor 20 Jahren, 15 Jahren, da gab es ja das Internet, so wie wir das heute kennen, noch nicht. Also das gab es zwar auch schon, so wie wir es heute kennen, aber nicht in Deutschland, sondern...
Nein, in den Monies gab es das schon.
1979? Also in den 80er Jahren, so die Dortmunder, die haben sich auch ziemlich lange, die Unidu auch noch ziemlich lange über USCP versorgt, bevor die richtige IP-Connectivity hatten. Das war noch in den 80ern, waren die irgendwie noch nicht so weit. Und dann ging das irgendwann Mitte der 80er Jahre los, mit dem Aufbau von so einer Internetinfrastruktur. Aber das hat halt auch lange gedauert, bis das wirklich zu den Endusern sozusagen kam.
Ich weiß, es kommt jetzt total blöd, aber wir haben gerade gesagt, wir haben überhaupt noch nicht gesagt, wer heute hier ist vom Chaos Computer Club.
Deswegen sind schon wieder alle super anonymer.
Anonymerie, Radio, egal. Tim ist da, wer noch?
Tobias ist da.
Der Mike ist immer noch da.
Und der Woow.
Tim, Tobias, Mike und Woow ist ein bisschen veränderte Mannschaft heute, aber das wechselt ja sowieso von Monat zu Monat. Ich glaube, Tim ist fast immer dabei gewesen, ich glaube ein oder zwei Mal nicht.
Aber ich kann auch gehen.
Nein, so meinte ich das nicht. Wir haben dich doch gerne hier. Ich finde das ja auch toll. Gut, aber gleich wieder zurück, damit du nicht den Faden verlierst. Wir gucken also ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit, wie das war zu Zeiten, als auch Modems noch nicht eine Geschichte war, die man bei Aldi an der Kasse mitgekriegt hat, wenn man Leertapes gekauft hat. Wir gucken ein bisschen zurück auf die Zeit, in der die Telefondosen noch sehr anders aussahen und vor allen Dingen zurück auf die Zeit, in der vor allen Dingen Übertragungsgeschwindigkeiten noch vierstellig waren.
Joli, fang noch mal an, erklär uns doch mal den Unterschied zwischen analog und digital.
Also der Unterschied zwischen analog und digital ist folgender. Ein digitales Signal ist eigentlich nur ein Signal, nämlich an oder aus, das ist eins und nullen. Im Gegensatz zum analogen Signal ist es sehr digital, weil es analog ist.
Wie viele Punkte können wir ihm dafür geben?
Ich könnte das besser erklären, wenn du mich nicht auf kalten Fuß erwischen würdest.
Na ja, tatsächlich ist das ja irgendwie auch so ein Grundverständnisproblem. Es wird immer so viel von Digitaltechnik geredet.
Versuch mal mal, ein analoges Signal, nein, ein digitales Signal ist ein Umgewand, ist ein innen... Ach du.
Wow, du hast halt ein schönes Gleichnis.
Also wenn man auf dem Kinderspielplatz geht, dann ist auf dem Kinderspielplatz üblicherweise eine Rutsche.
So wollte ich auch erst anfangen.
Oh nein, der Rutsche ist eine Treppe. Und jetzt geht man die Treppe hoch und dann rutscht man runter. Und die Rutsche ist analog, ein kontinuierlicher Übergang von oben nach unten. Und wenn man eine Treppe auf dem Hintern runterrutscht, die ganzen Stufen, dann spürt man den Unterschied zwischen analog und digital auf dem Hintern. Digital ist ein gestufter Vorgang, die Stufen können unterschiedlich hoch sein, sie können unterschiedliche Farben haben und die Treppe kann sogar auch noch rollen. Auch eine Rolltreppe ist eine digitale Maschine. Was wir heute in der Regel haben, sind Binäre-Maschinen. Die haben auch eine Treppe. Aber diese Treppe hat nur eine einzige Stufe. Und da gibt es nur unten oder oben.
Genau, also was man halt leicht auseinander, was man immer auseinander kriegen muss, ist, dass dieses Binäre ist sozusagen die heute übliche Ausprägung von digital. Aber digital heißt an sich grundsätzlich mit dem Fingerzeigend, also man kann es abzählen. Die Außenwelt ist ja nicht abzählbar. Wenn man sagt, wie groß ist ein Baum? Na ja, da kann man sagen, der ist irgendwie groß oder sehr groß oder ziemlich hoch. Aber wenn man das halt auf etwas Konkretes, vermittelbares, kommunizierbares runterbrechen will, dann bedient man sich eines Maßstabs. Das heißt, man legt eine kleinste, interessante Einheit an. Zum Beispiel einen Zentimeter und drückt es dann darin aus. Das heißt, man teilt diese Größe auf, auf einen Raster. Das Raster hat eine bestimmte Auflösung. Ich sag jetzt mal einen Zentimeter. Und daraus kommt irgendwie, der Baum ist, was weiß ich, 18 Meter und 34 hoch. Dabei habe ich eine Abstraktion vorgenommen, weil es kann sein, dass er tatsächlich ja noch etwas höher oder etwas niedriger ist. Aber meine Auflösung Zentimeter greift an der Stelle eben nicht. Es gibt sozusagen einen Rundungsfehler, der für mich aber unter Umständen nicht mehr relevant ist. So wie man auf einer CD ja auch die Musik digital speichert mit einer bestimmten Auflösung, nämlich 16-Bit. Und man sagt halt einfach, na okay, das 17-Bit interessiert uns nicht mehr. Da wird halt zwangsläufig gerundet. Da kann man natürlich wieder die Plattenspieler frieken und sagen, ich hör das, ich hör das, und das glaube ich ihnen sogar auch. Aber es ist ja ganz praktisch mit dieser digitalen Geschichte, denn man hat die Möglichkeit, jegliche Informationen abstrakt zu fassen und mit einer Zahl auszudrücken. Und das erlaubt sozusagen eine einfachere Kommunikation.
Funktioniert das mit jeder Form von Information?
Ja.
Ja, da möchte ich jetzt mal ganz bissig einwerfen. Es gibt verschiedene Arten der Informationen. Das Morse-System ist eines der ersten wirklichen digitalen Systeme, und zwar kein binäres System. Es kennt nämlich mehr als zwei Zustände. Da gibt es kurz und lang, also Punkt und Strich. Und SOS heißt di-di-di, da-da-da, di-di-di. Und diese drei Punkte hintereinander sind ein S. Und die drei Striche sind ein O. Aber es gibt auch noch unterschiedliche Zwischenräume. Es gibt die Pause innerhalb eines Buchstapens. Zwischen den drei Punkten ist eine ziemlich kurze Pause. Die Pause ist so kurz wie der Punkt. Zwischen zwei Buchstaben ist eine etwas längere Pause. Die ist etwas so lang wie ein Strich. Und zwischen zwei Worten ist eine noch längere Pause. Also es gibt kurz und lang. Und es gibt drei Pausen. Also insgesamt fünf verschiedene Elemente.
Sind die Längen der Pausen denn definiert?
Ja, das ist dann die Handschrift des Funkers. Und da kommt es jetzt auch auf die übertragene Information an. Zum einen gibt es ja die Information des Mausenspruchs an und für sich. Und zum anderen gibt es noch die Handschrift des Funkers. Das ist so was ähnliches wie der Klavierspieler, der die Noten in einer bestimmten Art spielt. Und jeder Klavierspieler spielt meinetwegen das gleiche Stück von Mozart trotzdem anders. Und für die Handschrift der Funker wurden dann im Zweiten Weltkrieg dann eben auch meinetwegen gewisse Untergrundfunker an ihre Handschrift erkannt und dafür umgebracht.
Jetzt ist uns halbwegs klar, was dieses digitale Signal ist, aber wie aus einem analogen Signal, also aus einer Sprache, aus einem Video, aus Ton, aus einem Text wieder raus ein digitales Signal wird.
Der Text ist ja auch schon digital.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Schrift ist ja eigentlich auch schon...
Genau, das Herunterbrechen auf 26 Buchstaben, und das Aufschlüsseln von Worten und Silben in diese Buchstaben. Auch das ist eine Digitalisierung. Denn in dem Moment, wo das Wort vorliegt, ist es klar beschrieben. Es ist eindeutig. Und das verändert sich irgendwie nicht. Also nur durch Übertragungsfehler, die man dann aber wiederum deutlich erkennen kann.
Wobei ein Wort natürlich interpretierbar ist und eine digitale Information eigentlich nicht...
Interpretierbar? Was meinst du damit?
Naja, also wenn ich sage, dass Schriftzeichen eigentlich auch eine Art der Digitalisierung sind von Worten, die ich sage, die ich spreche, hat es trotzdem immer noch einen interpretierbaren Inhalt.
Ja, das ist dann irgendwie... da kommen wir zu Syntax und Semantik, nicht? Aber grundsätzlich geht es einfach nur darum, Digitalisierung führt einfach Zeichensätze ein oder führt Alphabete ein oder eben auch Zahlensysteme. Und bei Computern funktioniert das halt intern alles binär, weil man damit Strom an Strom aus relativ schnell vorankommt. Die ersten Computer waren nicht unbedingt alle binär. Es gibt auch noch ältere Sachen als Morse, also das ist jetzt nicht so wichtig, aber auch so Flaggenalphabet zum Beispiel, was auf Schiffen verwendet wurde, sind auch alles solche digitalen Kommunikationsprotokolle. Na ja, irgendwann ging das halt mit den Computern los und dann ging das eben auch mit den Datennetzen los. Also der Bedarf, Informationen digital zu kommunizieren, war halt da. Und dazu wurden dann zunächst einmal spezialisierte Datennetze aufgebaut. Ein gutes Beispiel ist das Telex-Netz zum Beispiel. Kennt man heute eigentlich kaum noch so. Also noch vor 10 Jahren war ein Mittelständler der Meinung, wenn er eine neue Firma aufmacht, dann braucht er halt ein Telefon, ein Telefax und auch einen Telex-Anschluss. Etwas, glaube ich, dem sich heute irgendwie nicht mehr so sehr viele Leute...
Das war zum Beispiel das einzige Datennetz, was in den Ostblock-Ländern richtig funktioniert hat.
Und Afrika.
Und was auch bis zum Schluss sehr teuer war, oder? Also ich weiß gar nicht von wegen Schluss. Telex wurde natürlich noch benutzt, wahrscheinlich, aber...
Jetzt muss ich gleich nochmal nachdenken. Also Tele-Text... Das ist der Nachfolger davon.
Da ist es ein gescheiterter Zwischenversuch. Bei den Preisen vom Telex-System spiegeln sich auch noch die alten Kolonialstrukturen wieder. Das heißt, von London aus war es günstig, in die englischen Kolonien Telex zu machen, von Paris aus in die französischen Netze. Und das waren dann so in den größeren Firmen auch die ersten Umweggeschichten. Da gab es dann in London meinetwegen Büros. Da standen zwei Telex-Maschinen. Auf der einen kamen Lochstreifen rein. Und auf der anderen ging er wieder raus, weil die Telexgebühren von Deutschland nach London und in eine ehemalige britische Kolonie zusammen immer noch weniger als die Hälfte waren, als wenn man von Deutschland direkt dorthin gegangen ist. Also die Telexpreise waren extrem hoch.
Ja, das hat sich auch heute noch nicht so richtig geändert.
Ja, das hält sich immer noch. Ich meine, das ist bei Telefonnetzen heute so, beim Internet ist es immer noch so.
Alles schön teuer. Naja, jetzt brauchte man halt sozusagen einen Zugang zu diesem Netz. Das war halt das Telexgerät. Und dafür gab es dann auch einen Telexanschluss, über dessen technische Details ich jetzt nicht ganz im Klaren bin. Was war das? Das waren 50 Bit pro Sekunde, die da irgendwie rübergingen. Und wie war die Termination?
Das war ein All-in-One-Gerät. Das war Eingabe, Ausgabe und Drucker, alles in einem Gerät.
Das war eine Vierswertleitung.
Aber das war eine digitale Schildstelle. Genau, also das ist halt das Besondere an einem Netzzugang, ob er über ein anderes Netz geht oder ob es ein Native Interface ist, also ob er sozusagen direkt rangeht. Bei den ersten Datennetzen gab es da gar keine andere Lösung. Also bei TEDx hat man halt ein spezielles TEDx-Gerät und hat eine spezielle TEDx-Schildstelle, das dieses Gerät eben implementiert. Und darüber ging dann die Daten direkt digital rüber.
Und dazwischen war aber eine Telefonleitung.
Nein, eine TEDx-Leitung. Das war ein eigenes Netz, das nicht das Telefonnetz war.
Technisch war das eine serielle Schnittstelle, aber eben eine Stromschnittstelle. Da floss eben noch wirklich Strom drüber. Und außer den Einzelverbindungen gab es die ersten TEDx-Netze zwischen den Nachrichtenagenturen halt.
Das heißt, wenn ich ein TEDx bei mir ins Büro stellen wollte, musste ich mir auch einen TEDx-Anschluss legen lassen.
Genau.
Und die Geschwindigkeit ging dann so langsam hoch. Erstmal so 50% Steigerung auf 75 Bits pro Sekunde. Und der nächste Schritt war dann 150 Bits pro Sekunde. Und da waren die Nachrichtenagenturen schon relativ glücklich mit.
Was ist mit 110?
Das ist auch noch eine Zwischengröße. Also das ist, das Hauptproblem war die Mechanik dabei. Die Schlitten dieser elektrischen Schreibmaschinen, die da angesteuert waren, mussten sich auch noch bewegen. Und was einem heute etwas komisch vorkommt, wieso gibt es eigentlich 1, 5 Stopp-Bits? Das kommt im PM-Magazin stand dabei, wie das gemacht wird. Ganz einfach, das halbe Bit wird mit der doppelten Geschwindigkeit gesendet. Das ist natürlich...
Da, da lacht der Computer.
Das hat ganz einfache mechanische Ursachen gehabt, weil am Ende einer Zeile musste der schlittende Schreibmaschine vom rechten an den linken Rand zurückfahren. Das hat er nicht in der Zeit von einem Bit geschafft, obwohl man da Stoßdämpfer und alles Mögliche gemacht hat, um das Ding da zurück zu zerren.
Und da gab es halt keinen Zwischenpuffer.
Wenn man bei so langsamen Geschwindigkeiten wie 50 Bit per Sekunde dann noch alles auf zwei Stopp-Bit macht, in der der Wagen dann wieder zurückfahren muss, da hat man dann die Mechanik so rausgekitzelt, dass man es in einer als Halb Stopp-Bit gekriegt hat.
Der Wagen fährt doch nicht zurück, wenn ein Stopp-Bit kommt, der Wagen fährt zurück, wenn der Wagen Rücklauf kommt.
Ja, aber die Zeit für den Wagen Rücklauf, die hat nicht ausgereicht von rechts nach links. Da brauchte man auch noch die Zeit vom Stopp-Bit dazu.
Aha, also ich kenne einen ähnlichen Effekt von meinem MPS 801 Commodore Matrix Drucker, der auch immer nach der Simplexdruck machte, also immer nur von links nach rechts druckte. Und ich habe ihn dann locker um 50% beschleunigen können, indem ich einfach links ein Gummiband befestigt habe, was ihn also einfach mit doppelter Geschwindigkeit in der Links anschlagen ließ. Vielleicht solltest du noch kurz dazu erklären, was ein Stopp-Bit eigentlich ist. Es ist halt eine Eigenschaft der seriellen Datenübertragung.
Die serielle Datenübertragung ist so etwas ähnliches wie das Morsen mit der Taschenlampe. Da geht das Licht halt an und aus und da geht dann eben da entsprechend der Strom an und aus. Und genauso wie man irgendwo feststellen muss, dass ein Morsezeichen zu Ende ist, muss man feststellen, dass ein Zeichen zu Ende ist. Und bei der seriellen Datenübertragung ist es nun nicht so wie bei den Morsezeichen, dass die Dinger unterschiedlich lang sind. Also das E ist bei Morsen beispielsweise ein einziger Punkt, hat nur ein einziges Signalelement. Beim üblichen seriellen Datenübertragung hat jedes Zeichen einfach 8 Bit. Und auf der Leitung gibt es dann erstmal ein Startbit, das heißt Achtung, jetzt geht's los. Dann geht die Schreibmaschine in die Grundstellung, so beim alten Telex. Und die Zahnräder warten jetzt für die nächsten Bits, dass sie irgendwie umklappen oder nicht umklappen. Und dann ist ein Buchstabe ausgewählt. Und wenn das Stopbit kommt, dann wird der Buchstabe aufs Papier genagelt. Und danach ist dann kommt wieder das Startbit, dass die Mechanik in die Grundstellung gehen kann. Und die Mechanik ist irgendwann weggefallen, aber die ganzen Prinzipien mit Start und Stopbit sind geblieben.
Telex war also ein in sich geschlossenes System, was mit Telefonleitungen nichts zu tun hatte. Kam gleich danach dann Datex P, BTX und lief dann über Telefonleitungen? Oder war dazwischen noch irgendwas anderes in Deutschland jetzt?
Also der nächste Schritt war meines Wissens X25. Also Telex bediente ja auch nur Verbindungen. Und ziemlich schnell wurde einem klar, dass man irgendwie für ein Computernetz, ein wirklich gut funktionierendes Computernetz, im Prinzip Paketvermittlung braucht. Also man nicht wie beim Telefonnetz eine Verbindung aufbaut, darüber dein Daten rüber schickt und das beendet, sondern dass jedes einzelne Datenpaket, was ein Computer herauslässt, für sich getrennt weitergeleitet wird. So wie es heute auch im Internet der Fall ist. Und als es aber noch kein IP gab und das Ganze auch noch auf einer viel niedrigeren Ebene entwickelt wurde, wurden halt sogenannte X25 Netze aufgebaut, weltweit. X25, das kann man ja den Begriff schon ansehen, ist halt so ein CCITT-Standard, auf dem sich halt diese ganzen Post- und Telekommunikationsmonopolisten der Welt darauf geeinigt haben. Das sind auch ziemlich ausgefallte Standards, wo viele Wissenschaftler und Akademiker eine Menge Zeit drauf verwenden und die Papiere dann teuer verkaufen.
Und ITU übrigens inzwischen.
Mittlerweile heißt das ITU, International Telecommunications Union. Und X25 war ein relativ robuster Standard, der sich dann sehr gut durchgesetzt hat. Aber auch hier, hier das gleiche Spiel, wenn man halt am X25 Datennetz teilnehmen möchte, in Deutschland hieß das dann Datex T, braucht man eben einen speziellen X25-Anschluss, der nicht ein Telex-Anschluss ist und der auch nicht ein Telefonanschluss ist und der auch nicht ein ISDN-Anschluss ist. Gab's ja auch alles schon weit, weit vor ISDN.
Ja, da gab's ja irgendwie Hauptanschlüsse und Einwahlanschlüsse.
Ähm, genau, eigentlich... Ja, also die Einwahlen...
Und komme ich gleich zu...
Also der eigentliche Native-Zugang zu diesem Netz ist der sogenannte X25 Hauptanschluss. Das bedeutet eigentlich nur, dass man eben auch mittels des X25-Protokolls in dieses Netz reingeht. Das ist ein relativ teurer Anschluss gewesen. Da braucht man dann auch ein entsprechendes Gerät, irgendwie einen Computer. Später waren das dann PCs, wo man halt entsprechende Steckkarten reinsteckte. Und dann lief da eine Software drauf, die halt irgendwie X25-Protokoll sprach.
Muss ja alles zugelassen sein, irgendwie mit FTZ-Nummer und...
Also wir reden jetzt so von vor 15 Jahren etwa, ne?
Ja, 70er-Jahren kommt das hoch, ne, mit dem X25. Aber es läuft auch heute noch.
Hat da jemand Preise im Kopf?
Also so einen Hauptanfluss kostet der irgendwie 20.000 Mark.
Vielleicht mal ganz zu Anfang. Also in den 80ern war es dann nicht mehr so teuer, aber schon so ein paar hundert Mark.
Dann muss das dann irgendwie noch einen zugelassenen PC dazu haben, der eine FTZ-Nummer hatte, das war auch nicht so einfach.
Also nur auch mal zu veranschaulichen, wir reden ja hier immer nicht von vor 300 Jahren, sondern im Zeitrahmen sind demnächst dann vor 15 Jahren, jetzt sind wir bei 20, vor 25 Jahren. Wenn also in den 70ern allein der Anschluss für sowas noch 20.000 Mark kostet hat, weil wir oft auch von der Information, die frei sein soll, reden und so, war das also definitiv eine Elite-Geschichte. Das heißt Nachrichtenagenturen konnten oder mussten sich solche Geschichten leisten.
Banken vor allem.
Banken, einerseits eine Elite-Geschichte, auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch ein dermaßen abgeschirmtes und überschaubares System, was dann wahrscheinlich auch die Nachlässigkeit in Sachen Sicherheitsfragen heutzutage erklärt, weil die waren damals wahrscheinlich nicht so notwendig.
War nicht so notwendig, aber in gewisser Hinsicht des X5 war es ein relativ sicheres System gewesen, weil man von vornherein Caller-Aussentification hatte. Das heißt, jedes Paket, was man halt erhielt, war klar ersichtlich, woher es kam. Und das ist in dem X25 Standard alles relativ gut geregelt. Und deswegen wurde es halt auch relativ früh von Banken verwendet. Alle EC-Automaten zum Beispiel hatten halt einen X25 Anschluss und haben darüber ihre ganze Kommunikation gemacht. Das ist auch teilweise heute noch so. Das geht jetzt langsam auf ISDN-Technologie. Und im Prinzip sind diese ganzen X25 Netze, gehen auch in zunehmendem Maße in den digitalen Telefonnetzen auf. Aber es gibt sie halt noch.
Wie schnell war sowas?
Der normale Anschluss war so 9, 6. 9600 Bit pro Sekunde, also wirklich nicht schnell. Und später dann aber auch schnellere Anschlüsse bis zu 2 Megabit gab es auch X25.
Aber mal als Vergleich von der Geschwindigkeit, wie das nutzbar war, gibt es noch eine Variante von dem X25, nämlich das AX25. Das ist die Amateurfunk-Variante davon. Die hat eben eine etwas längere Adressierung. Und dabei passt in die Adresse ein komplettes Amateurfunkrufzeichen rein. Und so um 1980 haben die bundesdeutschen Amateurfunker einfach durch Funkstationen in der Luft, die sie im Selbstbau hingestellt haben, Übertragungsgeschwindigkeiten auf ihren Funkstrecken hingekriegt, die in etwa dem Datex P-Netz der Post entsprochen haben. Also so berauschend war das nicht. Das war für kurze Knappe militärische und staatliche Führungskommunikation, sowie für die Spitzen der Wirtschaft gedacht. Und so hundertprozentig sicher, sage ich mal, war das auch nicht. Man konnte sich eben auch bereits vor 15 Jahren dann in diese Kisten reinwählen, ging dann meinetwegen in irgendeinen Computer rein und von dem Computer auch wieder raus. Und wenn man das so mit drei, vier Computern hintereinander gemacht hat, dann war auch nicht mehr klar, wo man herkam.
Ja, vorausgesetzt, dass man überhaupt erst mal reinkommt. Das wurde ja dann durch... Also, Datix P war an sich schon gut durchdacht, nur haben sie dann eingesehen, dass irgendwie nicht jeder unbedingt einen Hauptanschluss haben will, weil das halt irgendwie teuer Equipment ist und es gab auch sozusagen einen gewissen mobilen Bedarf. Und dazu hat dann die Telekom Modem-Zugänge auch geschaltet. Zum Modems kommen wir ja nachher nochmal. Und da das ja eigentlich ein Paketnetzwerk war und ein Modem ja keine Pakete verschickt, sondern einen permanenten Datenstrom hat, ist dieser Zugang PET, P-A-D, Packet, Assembly and Disassembly. Und das war sozusagen das Hacker-Türchen. Weil beim PET hat man nun eine ganz normale Telefonnummer, die ruft man an, dann meldet sich irgendwie so ein Datex-P-Prompt. Irgendwie, hallo, ich Datex-P, gib deine NUI ein. Die NUI war die Network User Identification. Das war sozusagen einfach nur eine Kennnummer. Und wenn man die eben hatte, gab es ein Passwort? Und mit dem Passwort hatte, dann war man sozusagen so im Datex-P-Netz angemeldet, als hätte man einen Hauptanschluss, nur dass die Daten eben von dem Modem ausgehen. Dann hat man also nun die NUI von jemand anderem, und die waren damals relativ einfach zu gewinnen, auf Messen und anderen Bereichen. So, dann wurde da halt fleißig gehackt. Und das war im Prinzip die erste Hacker-Plattform. Das heißt, das Internet ist von Deutschland aus eigentlich nur über das Datex-Netz zu erreichen gewesen. Das heißt, über Datex-Zugänge hat man sich an bestimmte Rechner gewandt, zum Beispiel an die Hacker-Fahrschule des CERN in der Schweiz. Und von dort aus lagen dann wiederum andere Datex-Leitungen oder andere X-25 oder sonstwie geartete Leitungen in die USA, in die Militärnetze und so weiter.
Im Chat kamen gerade so ein paar schnippische Kommentare. Da kann man wieder sehen, dass die Jugend einfach unfähig ist, ein bisschen aus der Vergangenheit auch zu lernen. Da kam dann die Frage, was da mit Flaschenbrust ist. Wobei die nächste Frage, was denn zum Thema Rauchzeichen, nämlich die war gar nicht so blöd, wie sie vielleicht gemeint war. Rauchzeichen, um noch mal ganz kurz noch ein Stück weiter zurück zu gehen, zu den Mausezeichen sind natürlich genau was ähnliches wie auch die Mausezeichen. Insofern eigentlich auch eine Digitalisierung. Ja, lass mal ein bisschen kurz Sounds hören und dann weitermachen mit den nächsten Schritten nach X25. Natürlich werden wir nicht in der Vergangenheit bleiben, wir werden zur Gegenwart kommen, wir werden auch zur Zukunft kommen. Falls ihr aber Fragen zu diesen älteren Technologien habt, könnt ihr zwischendurch gerne hier anrufen unter der bekannten Fritznummer 0331 für Potsdam 7097 110. Bleibt aber bitte erst mal so in der Zeitspanne, in der wir uns gerade befinden, denn zu den anderen Sachen kommen wir natürlich erst mal selber noch. Und ich kann ja gleich mal eine dode Frage stellen, denn wenn wir jetzt auf das Telefonnetz zu sprechen kommen, nach diesen ganzen Kramdiensten, nach den eigenen Netzen, die es vorher gab, hat sich mir mal die Frage gestellt, als technisch nicht so richtig versierter Mensch in der Hinsicht, das ist doch ein komplett analoges Netz gewesen, das Telefonnetz eigentlich. Jetzt wird das digitalisiert, oder ist es schon fast? Am Anfang wurde doch tatsächlich nur die Sprache so übermittelt, wie sie ist. Also es war eine akustische Lösung eigentlich, oder?
Nein, es war eine galvanische Lösung. Also die Schallwellen wurden halt in Strom umgewandelt. Das war halt die eigentliche bahnbrechende Erfindung des Telefons.
Also komplett analog?
Genau, komplett analog. Also würde ich eine 1 zu 1 umsetzen, nur dass eben irgendwie aus den Schallwellen durch das Kohlemikrofon eben in Stromwellen umgewandelt wurde.
Ich sage jetzt mal nicht dazu, dass ich auch das noch nicht richtig begriffen habe. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, wie Radio geht insofern.
So ähnlich. Auf Radio ist chronisch analog an der Stelle. Das, was du da reinhustest, setzt du halt direkt in eine elektromagnetische Schwingung.
Nein, ich glaube hier kommt es inzwischen...
Du kommst super elektromagnetisch rüber, Johnny. Ich bin mir sicher.
Ach, das hat noch keine Frau zu mir gesagt. Gut, also da haben wir dieses analoge Telefonnetz. Wie sind wir da weitergegangen? Wie hat man versucht daraus Netzwerk... Auf jeden Fall war es schon bestehendes Netzwerk. Telefone waren schon verbunden. Eigentlich hatte man was, worauf man zurückgreifen konnte.
Ich denke, dass man die Feststellung, dass es sich bei dem Telefonnetz auch wirklich um ein Netzwerk handelt, ist eine wichtige Feststellung. Im Prinzip ist auch das Telefonnetz mit den gleichen Grundideen aufgebaut wie es heute auch Computernetze sind. Dass man eine verteilte Struktur hat und dass man ein Routing benötigt, um Anrufe herzustellen, um Verbindungen herzustellen, anhand der Rufnummer ein Weg gefunden werden muss. Das Telefonnetz ist nun mal das älteste Netz, weil es natürlich auch am meisten benutzt wird, weil es einfach die Killer-Application war für Telekommunikation. Man will halt miteinander sprechen. Auch Handys haben sich nicht erst als Datentransportgeräte durchgesetzt, sondern natürlich weil die Leute darüber plappern wollen. Und allein die Existenz dieses Telefonnetzes machte es natürlich zwangsläufig zu dem Number One Wunschnetz, um auch darüber Daten übertragen zu können, weil es gab in jedem Land Telefonnetze und vor allem alle Telefonnetze waren mit allen Telefonnetzen verbunden.
Ach naja, das ist aber noch nicht sehr lange so.
Okay, also viele Telefonnetze waren mit vielen Telefonnetzen, also es war im Prinzip immer der Wunsch, alle miteinander zu verbinden, auch wenn halt am Anfang ein bisschen Fräulein vom Amt oder der Geheimdienst, die Stasi noch dazwischen irgendwie ihre Stöpsel steckte, bevor es wirklich weiterging. Du meinst jetzt irgendwie direkt durch, weil es halt eine Weile gedauert hat, ne?
Ist das eigentlich in den USA?
Die USA sind da hinten dran. Sind die jetzt fertig? Das weiß ich noch nicht. Der erste Selbstwähldienst war 1928 in Deutschland. Und da waren die Amis noch lange nicht so weit. Nur hat es eine ganze Weile gedauert, bis sich das durchgesetzt hat. Also insbesondere eben nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg erst der Selbstwählferndienst innerhalb Deutschlands. Und dann kam eben so Stück für Stück der internationale Dienst.
Da hat man sich doch immer gewundert bei alten amerikanischen Spielfilmen, oder? Dass sie einen Hörer abnehmen und sagen Operator. Oder ich weiß nicht, verbinden sie mich bitte mit...
Chicago 357.
Genau, ich fand das schick. Dabei war es eigentlich komplett anders. Ich wollte auch meinen Hörer abheben und sagen, verbinden sie mich mit...
Aber das haben die Amis ja heute noch. Da steht auf der Null immer noch Operator drauf. Und wenn man die Null drückt, kriegt man auch immer noch den Operator und kann dem auch immer noch sagen, verbinden sie mich bitte mit sowieso.
Oder wenn man im Telefonzelle steht, oder Telefonzellen gibt es ja nicht, aber diese öffentlichen Telefonapparate, dass wenn man da abhebt und dann erst mal wählt, dann schaltet sich erst mal ein Operator dazwischen und sagt, darf uns jetzt bitte folgende Summe ein. Also hallo, ich wollte gar nicht mit Ihnen reden.
Die erste Digitalisierung im bundesdeutschen Telefonnetz begann in den 60er Jahren und zwar gar nicht wegen der Datenübertragung, sondern um einfach Kosten zu sparen. Da ging es dann so los mit den großen Neubauvierteln in Hamburg und da haben dann die Postler in Hamburg ein Verfahren entwickelt, um Telefonate zu bündeln. Wenn die Sprache übertragen wird, also wenn man sich das so vorstellt, einen Sinuston, den kann man sich noch nicht nur anhören, sondern auch noch so vorstellen als Kurve, dann schaut man eben entsprechend genug nach, wie hoch gerade der Ton ist, setzt das in Zahlenwert um und überträgt dann diesen Zahlenwert. Und wenn man das dann meinetwegen 8.000 Mal pro Sekunde macht und dann auf 256 mögliche Lautstärken, also auf 8 Bit reduziert, dann hat man eine relativ überschaubare Elektronik zu bauen, die man schon in den 60er Jahren locker hinkriegte. Und dann hat man einen ganz einfachen Trick gemacht. Man hat nämlich diese Signale 32 Mal so schnell übertragen. Das heißt, man hat 32 Telefonate auf eine einzige Leitung gepackt. Also jeweils immer erst kommt der Abtastwert für Gespräch 1, dann kommt der Abtastwert für Gespräch 2 bis Gespräch 30 und dann kommt nochmal ein Abtastwert, den man überträgt. Und in dem drin ist, Tante Emma will mit Lotte telefonieren, also die Verbindungsinformation. Und dann hat man noch einen Zeitschlitz und in dem wird eine Synchronisierinformation übertragen. Also eine Information, wo es losgeht. Damit sich das Ding wieder fängt. Und damit ist es möglich, also das kriegt man auch noch auf gewöhnlichen Telefonträten hin, diese Datenmenge, also 64 Kilobit mal 30, also 2 Megabit. Da braucht man noch keine Coax-Leitung, das machen die gewöhnlichen Trädchen, die in der Landschaft liegen. Aber damit hat man auf 4 Trädchen, jeweils 2 für hin und 2 für zurück, 30 Telefonate gleichzeitig. Und das hat man damals bei den großen Neubausiedlungen in Hamburg gemacht. Da hat man nämlich auf 4 Telefonleitungen, also auf 4 Trädchen, die man so zu einem Wohnblock gelegt hat, gleich 30 Telefonate gleichzeitig übertragen können. Als Vermittlungsstelle hat man da irgendwie einen rostschutzsicher angestrichenen LKW hingestellt. Da waren Beschaltungseinheiten für 1000 Teilnehmer drin. Und von dort wurden nur ein paar Trädchen gelegt, jeweils 4 für 30 Teilnehmer. Und dann hatte man einen kompletten Wohnblock angeschlossen. Und dieser LKW, der irgendwo auf der Wiese stand, der war die Telefonvermittlungsstelle. Und der hat für die Bundespost das Geld verdient, dass man tatsächlich eine Vermittlungsstelle dort hinbaut. Das Telefonnetz in Deutschland war schon lange digitalisiert, bevor die meisten überhaupt begriffen, was Digitalisierung ist. Aber eben nicht auf der Ebene, dass da in Anführungsstrichen wirklich Daten übertragen wurden im Sinne von, wie wir es heute betrachten. Sondern eben nur, dass man die analogen Daten auf den Zwischenstrecken von einer Mini-Vermittlung, nahe von einem Wohnblock meinetwegen, bis zur nächsten Vermittlungsstelle als digitale Päckchen auf weniger Träten überträgt. Dort wurden sie wieder ausgepackt und analog weiter transportiert oder eben umgepackt und auch digital weiter transportiert.
Meistens aber dann natürlich erstmal analog. Das war erstmal so Patchwork-mäßig, wurde halt Stück für Stück das Telefonnetz durch Digitaltechnik erweitert, bis sie dann irgendwann dazu übergegangen sind, auch die ganze Vermittlung selber digital zu machen. TDM nennt man das, ne? Time Division Multiplex, die Methode.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber historisch ist interessant, dass das dazu geführt hat, indem man diese Untervermittlungsstellen gebaut hat, dass in Deutschland im Weltvergleich die letzte Meile statistisch relativ kurz ist. Wie denn? Das teuerste sind ja die zwei Drädchen, die der Kunde exklusiv in Hürde gelegt kriegt. Das ist das Allerteuerste. Und ab dem ersten Punkt, wo man diese Drädchen zusammenbündeln kann, spart man als Netzbetreiber Geld. Und von daher hat man sich bemüht, diese Vermittlungsstellen, soweit es geht, irgendwie zu verteilen und die teuren Drädchen, die jeder einzelne in die Wohnung gelegt kriegt, die möglichst kurz zu halten.
Er hört Chaos Radio, Computerblumen bei Fritz, normalerweise jeden Mittwoch im Monat, diesmal ausländsweise am ersten Mittwoch im Monat. Sind wir denn eigentlich jetzt, Tim, sind wir dann aber Ende März wieder dran oder wie läuft das?
Jaja, also ab jetzt lassen wir uns glaube ich den Termin auch nicht mehr entnehmen.
Dann sind wir ja in drei Wochen schon wieder dran.
So sieht das aus, gleich nach der CeBIT. Wir haben sogar schon ein Thema-Fach gelebt, ja. Sag nur mal. Das heißt Spezialkomputer. Genau, also zum Beispiel PDAs, kleine Computer, alles was nicht, deshalb kennen sie alle. Dann brauchen wir ja nicht zu kommen, die Sendung erlauben wir.
Ne, ihr braucht nicht kommen, die Sendung erlauben wir.
Handys sind auch Spezialkomputer, Communicator-Systeme, Wearables.
Vielleicht sollten wir aber bei Nokia anrufen und nach fünf Testgeräten fragen. Also eigentlich jeden letzten Mittwoch, Monat und dann auch im März. Das Thema heute heißt allerdings Netzzugangstechnologien. Die Musik kommt von Agent Me. Das sind Live-Aufnahmen von den beiden. Und was gibt es noch zu sagen? Wo sind wir denn jetzt angelangt? Wo machen wir denn weiter? Gehen wir langsam ein bisschen in die Gegenwart, damit wir auch noch zur Zukunft kommen.
Naja, Vau hat ja gerade schön erklärt, wie eben die Digitalisierung ins Netz eingezogen ist. Aber was uns ja eigentlich mehr interessiert, ist ja nun der Netzzugang. Und beim Telefonnetz war der Netzzugang halt lange, lange Zeit nur analog. Auch wenn auf bestimmten Zwischenstrecken hier und da schonmal was digital gemacht wurde, damit irgendwie größere Bandbreiten möglich sind und damit das irgendwie alles billiger ist. Aber der eigentliche Zugang war analog. Das heißt, ein normaler Telefonanschluss besteht einfach aus zwei Kabeln. A und B, die gehen direkt ins Telefon rein. Und wenn da irgendwie Wechselstrom drauf ist, dann fängt das Telefon an zu klingeln. Und wenn man irgendwie anfängt eben darüber zu sprechen, dann beeinflusst man eben den Strom auf diesen Leitungen. Und da das Telefonnetz nun so schön groß war und so schön verbunden war weltweit, bestand natürlich der Bedarf, darüber auch Computerdaten zu versenden. Und das Problem ist, ich möchte digitale Daten versenden über ein analoges System. Und das geht halt erstmal nicht so ohne weiteres. Bei Telex hatte man eben eine direkte digitale Schnittstelle. Das heißt, dieses Telex-Gerät, so simpel es war, konnte seine digitalen Informationen, die man da eingetippt hat, den Text, den man versenden möchte, mehr oder minder direkt ohne irgendeine Wandlung über diese Schnittstelle übertragen. Die war zwar langsam, aber sie war immerhin digital. Und beim Telefonnetz, was eben für Sprechen ausgelegt war, hatte man diesen Komfort nicht. Und deswegen muss man zunächst einmal die digitalen Daten so wandeln, dass sie eben einen analogen Weg beschreiten können. Das nennt man dann DA-Wandlung, also Digital Analog Wandlung, oder etwas komplizierter ausgedrückt Modulation. Das heißt, modulieren bedeutet, ich nehme diese digitale Information, diese Zahl und wandle sie in einen analogen Wert um einen Zustand auf dieser analogen Leitung, der diese Zahl ausdrückt. Und auf der anderen Seite kommt eben dieses analoge Signal so an und wird dort wieder demoduliert, also wieder zurückgeführt in eine digitale Information, im günstigsten Fall natürlich in die, die man losgeschickt hat. Und aus diesen Begriffen Modulation, Demodulation hat sich eben der Begriff Modem gebildet. Ach, das ist ein religiöser Krieg für sich, ob das der, die oder das Modem heißt. Kann man sehen, wie man will. Was sagst du denn?
Ich sag das Modem. Aber eigentlich finde ich, wäre grammatikalisch der Modem richtiger. Der Demodulator Modulator.
Das ist völlig richtig. Danke schön. Die Bundespost hat lange darauf beharrt, aber die normative Kraft des Faktischen hat bewirkt, dass jeder sagt, das Modem, das Ding, was da rumsteht, dieser blinkende Kasten, wenn man keinen Anschluss kriegt und bei der Hotline anruft. Was für ein Modem haben Sie? Modem, weiß ich nicht, was das ist. Ist das dieser blinkende Kasten? Ja, den habe ich in Weihnachtsbaum gehängt. Am besten, Sie lassen ihn dort hängen.
Im Chat wird gerade vorgeschlagen, Dipp Modem. Eigentlich auch ein schöner...
Beim Modem gibt es nun technische Probleme, weil es ja... Oder gehen wir vom Akustikkoppler erstmal aus. Das war die erste Geschichte, dass man so Gummimuffen über das Telefon drüber gestülpt hat. Eine über das Mikrofon, eine über den Lautsprecher. Und damit hat man dann die Signale in diese Maschine eingekoppelt. Dazu musste man das Ding nicht aufschrauben und weiter nichts machen. Aber das Problem war, es gab einfach Störgeräusche. Wenn man zu laut gehustet hat, gab es bei der Datenübertragung Fehler. Die Möglichkeiten, dort Informationen zu übertragen, waren einfach technisch beschränkt.
Jetzt solltest du erst mal erklären, warum es überhaupt in Deutschland dazu kam, dass so viele Leute akustische Kupplungen benutzen mussten.
Weil das Aufschrauben schon der Telefondose an der Wand verboten war. Das war also ungefähr, das war etwas schlimmer bestraft als das fahrlässige Auslösen einer atomaren Explosion. Das passiert halt in der Rechtsordnung gelegentlich sowas und wurde eben auch verfolgt.
Viele erinnern sich vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr so richtig dran, dass heutzutage hat man da ja diese komischen TAE-Stecker, um irgendwie das Telefon in die Dose zu stecken. Und da ist dann meistens auch noch Platz für halt die Anrufbeantworter oder Faxgerät oder Modem eben. Aber früher war das ja halt alles fest verschraubt. Da kam man ja irgendwie ohne weiteres gar nicht so ran. Und wenn irgendwie der Postler dann mitgekriegt hatte, dass man da drin rumgeschraubt hat, war das irgendwie eher minder lustig.
Also ich kann mich da in wilde Konstruktionen erinnern von Mailboxen. Die hatten den Akustikkoppler in den Hördämmen drin stecken und unter das Telefon eine intektive Kopplung gestoppt. Und wenn das Telefon geklingelt hat, gab es dann so ein Lego oder Fischertechnik dran, da die Gabel hochgehoben hat. Und dann ging es los.
Ich kenne auch die Variante, dass von der Modelleisenbahn die Lok über eine Seilwinde, ein Gewicht, was auf der Gabel lag, vorwärts geschoben hat. Und die Lok ist halt vorwärts oder rückwärts gefahren, um abzuheben oder aufzulegen. Und diese Konstruktion stand dann unter dem Bett, meint wegen. Da hat sie nicht gestört und da war genug Platz für den Fahrweg.
Aber gab es nicht irgendeine Verordnung, dass man das Telefon bloß mit der Hand bedienen darf?
Da gab es viele Gerichte, Berüchte und sonstiges. Also die normative Kraft des Faktischen hat dazu geführt, dass das einfach gemacht wurde. Und diejenigen, die damals Strafgescheide gekriegt haben, für die sind das meinetwegen heute historische Ehrendiplome, die man an der Wand hängen hat. Weil man hat das, was heute jeder tun muss, damals schon gemacht, obwohl man es nicht durfte. Also das ist der Preis, den man für den Fortschritt bezahlen muss.
Das war richtig Pionierarbeit.
Aber jetzt nochmal zurück zu den technischen Problemen. Mit einem Akustikkoppler kriegte man halt nicht so viel Informationen über den Draht, wie wenn man direkt elektrisch ran ging. Dann waren die Störungen der Umgebungsgeräusche, dass man mal gehustet hat oder zu laut Musik gehört hat, eben nicht mehr so störend. Trotzdem war es eben auch wichtig, erstmal damit anzufangen. Und um sowas im Selbstbau hinzukriegen, war damals das Problem, wie kriegt man Gummidichtungen? Und da sind dann Freunde in Hamburg durch den dortigen Baumarkt mit dem Telefonhörer gelaufen, durch die Sanitärabteilung und haben geguckt, welche Gummidichtungen passen denn über den Telefonhörer. Und die Dinger wurden dann beschafft. Da wurde dann Lautsprecher und noch ein Lautsprecher als Mikrofon reingemacht. Und das war dann die Ankopplung an den Telefonhörer. Dahinter kam dann ein Bausatz, so zum selber bauen, weil das ist immer die billigste Lösung im Vergleich zu was fertig kaufen, zumindest damals. Und dieses Ding hatte dann, weil das waren die Gummidichtungen vom Klo hinten, da wo das Frischwasser reinkommt zum Spülen, dieses Porzellan, der Porzellanstopfen hinten am Klo hat denselben Durchmesser gehabt, wie der Standard-Telefonhörer. Heute gibt es so viele Telefonsorten, da geht das nicht mehr. Damals gab es nur einen Amtstyp, einen Durchmesser. Und deshalb hieß dieses Ding, das Datenklo, das war unser Selbstbaumodem.
Damals entstand auch die Aussage, ab ins Internet oder gleich zu Obi.
Naja, ich wollte mal versuchen, ein bisschen Leben in die Sendung zu bringen.
Ich möchte nochmal, nee, nicht Leben, Leben ist genug drin.
Auf unserer Website auf Chaosradio.ch ist auch ein Foto von dem Datenklo in der Ankündigung von der heutigen Sendung.
Was mir noch mal wichtig ist, sind die Geschwindigkeiten.
Ganz kurze Zwischenfrage, diese Akustikkoppe, du sagst gerade, hat man diese Gummidichtung besorgt? Mit anderen Worten, wer hat denn die Dinger zuerst gebaut?
Die gab es natürlich schon von der Industrie, aber die waren fürchterlich teuer. Die kosteten dann 1000 Marktschein. Und es war jedenfalls nicht bezahlbar für unsere einen. Und die Gummidichtungen, die kosten heute noch, die gibt es heute noch in den Baumärkten. Ich habe mal vorm Konkret noch mal...
Die hängen aber jetzt unter Internet.
Aber die Übertragung war halt relativ langsam, damals nur mit 300 Bit pro Sekunde. In 33KMOD heutzutage ist 100 mal so schnell. Und wenn man überlegt, wie schnell ist denn 300 Bit pro Sekunde, das sind, wenn man das durch 10 teilt, also Startbit, 8 Datenbit, Stopbit, macht zusammen 10 Bit pro Zeichen, dann sind das 30 Zeichen pro Sekunde. Und wenn ich 21 sage, das ist so eine Maßeinheit beim Sprechen, wie lange eine Sekunde dauert, dann kann man sagen 21 hat 13 Buchstaben. Und dreimal 13 ist 39, also irgendwie liegt schon so in der Größenordnung von 30. Also kann man sagen, mit einem 300 Bit pro Sekunde Modem kann man dreimal so schnell kommunizieren, wie man spricht. Und so aus den Erfahrungen von damals dann mit der Technik kriegte man auch, wenn man direkt elektrisch ans Telefon ging, 1200 Bit pro Sekunde hin. Und das ist eine Geschwindigkeit, wo man nur Text angenehm mitlesen kann. 2400 Bit pro Sekunde, das ist dann, da muss man schon nach Luft schnappen, weil einiges ist zu schnell zum direkten Mitlesen, aber man kann noch mitkommen. Und das Ganze, was jetzt heute rüberkommt, ist einfach entsprechend schneller.
Es geht gleich nach dem Fritz-Kurz-Info weiter direkt in die Gegenwart. Ich mag die Nummer gerade so sehr, wir fangen die gleich nochmal an. Denn... Wir haben jetzt erstmal das Fritz Kurzinfo, wenn ich es gefunden hab. Jetzt hab ich es gefunden. Musik kommt von Agent Me und gleich fangen wir mit dem Stück nochmal an.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Denn, das ist 0 Uhr, 32.30 Uhr.
Fritz Kurzinfo, Ökosteuer. Der Bundestag hat die Gesetzesvorlage angenommen. Danach sollen zum 1. April die Benzin- und Energiepreise erhöht und die Beiträge zur Rentenversicherung gesenkt werden. Dem Gesetz muss noch der Bundesrat zustimmen. Einspruch. Kurz vor der geplanten Hinrichtung des Deutsch-Amerikaners Lagran hat ein Berufungsgericht in den USA einen Aufschub verfügt. Der Bundesstaat Arizona kündigte sofort eine Gegenklage an. Das Todesurteil gegen Lagran wegen Raubmordes soll in der Nacht vollzogen werden. Bananenkrieg. Die USA haben den vorläufigen Einzug von 100 Prozent Strafzoll auf bestimmte europäische Importwaren angeordnet. Das Geld muss auf ein Sperrkonto gezahlt werden, bis die Welthandelsorganisation entscheidet. Die USA verlangen von der EU, die Einfuhr von Bananen aus ehemaligen europäischen Kolonien zu beschränken. Ehrung. Die in Berlin lebende 85-jährige Elisabeth Wust erhielt den israelischen Titel Gerecht unter den Völkern. Die hatte während der Nazi-Diktatur jüdischen Bürgern das Leben gerettet. Die Geschichte der Lilly Wust war die Grundlage für den Kinofilm Amy und Jaguar. Fußball. Im Viertelfilade der Champions League gewann Bayern München gegen Kaiserslautern. Nicht sehr überraschend. 2 zu 0. Nachts 7 bis 5 Grad. Am Tage gelegentlich Schauer. 10 bis 14 Grad. Verkehr. Entliegen zur Zeit keine Verkehrsmeldung vor. Fritz wünscht weiterhin eine gute Fahrt.
Ich dachte gerade mal, das kommt ja nicht oft vor. Svenja Baumgartner mit dem Fritz-Kurzinfo.
Wer wiegt, der fliegt. Oh ja.
Und wie geht das?
Du kommst am Samstag um 14 Uhr zur Fritz Wiege und Fliegebox. Ehemals Popbox. Die Fritz Wiege und Fliegebox steht am Samstag ab 14 Uhr vom Palais am Funkturm auf dem Hammerschöllplatz in Berlin.
Super!
Und warum? Mensch, da ist die internationale Tourismusbörse. Da gibt es jede Menge Reisekataloge. Die schleppst du einfach ab und bringst sie zur Fritz Wiege und Fliegebox. Und dann? Dann werden deine Kataloge geworfen und wer am meisten auf die Waage bringt, also Kataloge, der fliegt nach San Francisco. Eine Woche lang mit Freund und Freundin oder so. Und beide gucken dann zusammen ein Konzert von Sugar Ray und Everlast. Ach so, wer wiegt, der fliegt. Also Samstag, 14 Uhr vor dem Palais am Funkturm, oder? Aber nur mit Fritz.
Weiter geht's mit dem Chaos Radio. Ich bin völlig angetan bei der Musik heute. Nicht, dass die Musik sonst schlecht wäre. Bei Meite nicht.
Aber sie ist heute trotzdem auch gut.
Extrem gut finde ich, ja. Kommt von Agent Me in diesem Fall heute und ist live aufgenommen. Das heißt nichts mit stundenlang vorproduziert und Overdubbed, sondern wirklich live so an Sequenzen und verschiedensten elektronischen, wahrscheinlich größtenteils Regitarengeräten fabriziert. Wir sind beim Thema Netzzugangstechnologien und ich habe gesagt, wir wollen jetzt langsam mal in die Gegenwart kommen.
Tun wir das? Heute will man ja ISDN haben.
Heute wollen wir doch alle ISDN haben. Ich schlendere ja gerne durch so Computer Großmärkte, weil die Gesprächsfetzen, die man da so mitkriegt, irgendwie immer sehr interessant, oft auch witzig sind. Und ich wollte nach einem bestimmten Produkt fragen und stand an dieser Theke, wo man halt so fragt nach Produkten. Ich weiß nicht, ich würde gerne den Namen nennen, weil das ist ja immer eine schöne Negativ-Werbung, aber mir fällt jetzt der Richtige nicht ein. Ich will jetzt keinen wissen, der es nicht verdient hat. Jedenfalls stand dann mein, der hatte ein ganz simples Problem. Also ein Kunde vor mir sagte dann, ja, ich habe mir so ein Modem gekauft und ich habe mir ganz normal einen Telefonanschluss und dann muss ich immer irgendwie die Stecker umstecken. Wenn ich mit dem Modem ins Netz gehe, gibt es da irgendwas. Und es gibt ja Leute, die sich nicht so sehr mit Telefonie beschäftigen. Und dann kann man dann sagen, dass es Verteilerdosen gibt oder irgendwie sowas. Stattdessen sagt der Verkäufer von diesem Laden, natürlich, ich habe die Antwort für Sie, ISDN. Und ich weiß nicht, kennt jemand die Situation, dass, ich meine, man ist ja selber oft in Situationen, wo man eine Information braucht in einem Laden, weil man es selber nicht besser weiß, und dafür gibt es ja Fachleute. Das ist aber nochmal eine ganz blöde Situation, als ebenfalls Kunde daneben zu stehen und so zu denken, der erzählt ihm gerade Scheiße. Und sich jetzt einzumischen, ist irgendwie feist und arrogant und doof. Aber wenn jemand eigentlich nur eine andere Telefondose braucht für 8, 95 Mark, und der versucht ihm zu erklären, dass er unbedingt einen ISDN-Anschluss braucht, weil dem Mann ging es nicht darum, dass er alles gleichzeitig machen kann, sondern einfach, das war ein ganz Materialproblem.
Das lag wahrscheinlich einfach daran, dass der Verkäufer das selber nicht verstanden hat.
Hat der Verkäufer nicht zugehört, oder dachte der jetzt irgendwie Provision?
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass da Provision aus war. Ich finde Computerverkäufer, und das hört man ja oft auch ganz besonders von Frauen, die in Computerläden gehen, sind einfach arrogante Säcke. Kistenschieber. Das ist so wie Plattenverkäufer sind auch oft arrogante Säcke.
Ja, oder Radio-Moderatoren gibt es ganz viele.
Na ja, alle, die sich irgendwie für Fachleute auf irgendeinem Gebiet halten.
Radio-Moderatoren, ganze Spinner. Echt, sondern anständig arbeiten gehen.
Genau, soll sich mal ISDN holen.
Genau.
So, damit haben wir eine schöne Überleitung zum Thema ISDN gefunden, wie ich finde.
Aber elegant.
Ja, nur schade, dass wir jetzt alle den Faden verloren haben.
Wir haben ihn nicht verloren, aber du bist glaube ich nicht an der Suche. Na, ISDN ist sozusagen die letzte Konsequenz gewesen. Nachdem die ganzen Telefonnetze aus wirtschaftlichen und technischen Gründen digitalisiert wurden, also auch die Vermittlungsstellen digital waren, war eigentlich nur noch das letzte Stück, die letzte Meile. Diese Drahtstrippe zum Kunden, die wurde halt nach wie vor analog betrieben. Und das Problem bei Modemübertragung ist ja, das System ist für Sprachübertragung ausgelegt und hat von daher nur einen bestimmten Frequenzbereich durchgelassen. Also von, helft mir mal, wo ging es los?
300 bis 3400 Hertz.
So, das ist der Frequenzbereich, der da durchgelassen hat.
3100.
3100 ist die Bandbreite. 300 bis 3400 Hertz, Punkt.
Genau. Und die Modems müssen halt einen ganz schönen Krampf anstellen, um da noch digitale Daten durchzubekommen. Tatsächlich würden die Leitungen aber mehr hergeben, wenn man sie eben nicht analog betreibt, sondern eben direkt digital betreibt. Also sich eigentlich auch konsequent digital an die digitale Vermittlungsstelle anschließen. Und das wird halt unter dem Namen ISDN verkauft. Also tatsächlich gibt es sowieso nur noch ein digitales Telefonnetz. Und mit ISDN ist man an keinem anderen Netz, an dem man nicht auch wäre, mit einem normalen analogen Anschluss. Man ist nur anders angeschlossen. Und dadurch, dass diese Frequenzbegrenzung, diese Sprachfrequenzbegrenzung wegfällt, ist eben eine höhere Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit möglich. Die liegt bei ISDN bei insgesamt 128 Kilobit aufgeteilt in zwei Leitungen.
144 Kilobit.
Okay, wir wollen es ganz genau erklären. In 144 Kilobit, die sich in drei Kanäle trennen. Einen hören wir da gerade. Also in zwei sogenannte Nutzkanäle, auch B-Kanäle genannt, die halt jeweils 64 Kilobit haben. Und dazu noch so ein 16 Kilobit Steuerkanal, über den die sogenannte Signalisierung gefahren wird. Also das, was man vorher in Band gemacht hat, mit irgendwie ratternden Telefonwählscheiben oder dann später mit den Tonwahl-Tasten, wo das Wählen auch mit Frequenzen gemacht wurde, ist bei ISDN die Sache getrennt. Da gibt es halt zwei Kanäle, wo nur Daten übertragen werden und die Signalisierung findet in einem eigenen Kanal, in dem sogenannten D-Kanal statt. Von daher ist ISDN eben einfach technisch gesehen was ganz anderes und erfordert auch entsprechendes Equipment. Also ISDN-Karten oder ISDN. Modems, wie sie dann heißen, obwohl das eigentlich Quatsch ist. Also es gibt gar keine ISDN Modems, da diese ISDN Modems nicht mehr modulieren und demodulieren, sondern sie tun genau das nicht. Sie verhalten sich allerdings dem Computer gegenüber halt so wie das vorher ein Modem tat, indem man es einfach hinten an die seriöne Schnittstelle anschließt. Deswegen hat man sie ISDN Modems genannt.
So langsam aber sicher wird es auch mal Zeit, dass ihr hier anruft. Es gibt natürlich wie in jedem Blue Moon eine Hotline.
Die Frizz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam, 7097110.
Und es geht uns um Fragen zur derzeitigen Situation in puncto Netzzugangstechnologien, falls da welche sind. Ruft uns an, wer ist denn da?
Hallo.
Hallo hier ist Robert. Hi, ich habe gerade von den ISDN-Kanälen geredet. In dem beiden B-Kanälen und dem einen D-Kanal. Da wollte ich mal fragen, also das müsste doch theoretisch sein, diesen D-Kanal selber vielleicht auch zu nutzen, weil im Sinne von, dass da keine Gebühren braucht sind, weil die B-Kanäle bezahlt man auch mit Gesprächsgebühren. Also ein D-Kanal dürfte doch vielleicht auch zum Chatten oder so reichen, oder?
Robert, das ist immer so schön. Wir brauchen hier irgendwann eine Webcam, weil es gibt Anrufer, da...
Ich hab die selber mal vorgeschlagen.
Die hatten wir ja auch schon öfter hier bei Fritz, aber... Machen wir auch noch. Es gibt Anrufer, da siehst du hier entweder so, dass die Leute irgendwie wieder mal nach den Süßigkeiten greifen oder ein Drink nehmen und so denken. Und dann gibt es Anrufer, da siehst du hier so vier nickende und grinsende Köpfe vor, die... Letzteres war bei dir jetzt gerade der Fall.
Ja, also na klar, da sind irgendwie auch schon mehrere Leute drauf gekommen. Natürlich kann man irgendwie über den D-Kanal tatsächlich auch Nutzdaten übertragen und nicht nur Steuerdaten. Die Telekom bietet das tatsächlich auch selber an. Das ist natürlich nicht kostenlos, es ist X31 quasi, Datex P über den D-Kanal. Aber ansonsten gibt es tatsächlich die Möglichkeit, versteckt Daten zu übertragen in Paketen, die normalerweise zur Anrufsignalisierung benutzt werden, in Setup-Paketen, womit man normalerweise einen Anruf aufbaut. Und da gibt es auch, ich glaube, entsprechende Tools für, die so etwas explizit machen. Allerdings hat die Telekom inzwischen die Möglichkeit, herauszufinden, also die kriegen inzwischen mit, wenn du halt verdammt viele Steuerungsdaten überträgst, die einfach deutlich mehr sind, als man an einem normalen ISDN-Anschluss zustande bringt, weil das läuft dann zum Beispiel halt so, dass du irgendwie hundertmal pro Minute quasi einen anderen Anschluss anrufst und halt immer nur sozusagen den Anruf rausschickst, den du dann gleich wieder abbaust, bloß um halt irgendwie ein paar Bytes zu übertragen. Und naja, die Telekom kann das halt inzwischen feststellen und mir wurde sogar berichtet, dass die sowas teilweise, wenn man das übertreibt, sogar in Rechnung stellen. Das heißt, dass man dann irgendwie auf seiner ISDN-Rechnung tatsächlich einen Posten hat für irgendwie Steuerungsdaten, Übermittlung oder sowas Ähnliches.
Steuerdaten, Übermittlungssteuer.
Aber wie gesagt, es gibt solche Tools, ich weiß nicht wo, also ich hab sowas selber noch nicht benutzt, aber es gibt solche Tools, die genau sowas halt machen, was sich jeder vorstellt.
Das ist aber nicht besonders befriedigend, weil du kriegst nicht sehr viel Daten drüber, weil man realistisch kann man derzeit nur mit dem Setup, also mit diesem Verbindungswunschaufbaupaket, Daten noch nur ein paar Bytes mit übertragen. Tatsächlich ist im ISDN-Standard vorgesehen, auch noch User-Data im D-Kanal, wirklich Ende zu Ende.
Genau, UUS, das ist User-to-User-Signaling, allerdings kostet das natürlich auch Kohle.
Genau, das haben sie irgendwann mal begriffen, dass das unter Umständen dazu führen kann, dass sie irgendwo kein Geld mehr verdienen und naja, das ist Preisgestaltung bei der Telekom.
Also wie gesagt, die versteckte Datenübertragung, Nutztatenübertragung im D-Kanal lohnt sich halt nicht, um tatsächlich irgendwie Internetzugang zu realisieren oder irgendwelche Files zu ziehen oder so zum Chatten reicht es allerdings. Allerdings ist man dann natürlich auch irgendwie, chatet man halt die ganze Zeit nur mit dem einen Teilnehmer, der am anderen Ende der Leitung sitzt.
Gute Idee so, schon drüber nachgedacht worden.
Wen haben wir denn da?
Wer ist da? Hallo?
Jo, ich habe ein paar Fragen jetzt nicht direkt zum Netzzugang, aber auch über ISDN und zwar Linux und Kapi und so weiter ist noch nicht, ne? Also es geht mir jetzt primär um Faxen und so.
Also doch, es gibt von AVM eine Karte, ich glaube die B1 oder so.
Ja genau, nur die aktiven, ne?
Jaja genau, und da gibt es auch tatsächlich eine Kapi für Linux. Aber ansonsten nicht.
Mir wurde bisher das immer so erklärt in diversen Newscripts und so weiter, dass die passiven Karten das nicht können, weil dieser Faxdatenstrom ja doch dann moduliert werden muss erstmal.
Also demoduliert werden muss praktisch, ne? Genau, da muss halt vom Rechner so getan werden, als würde der halt irgendwie, der übernimmt quasi die Aufgabe des Modems, also das was normalerweise halt entsprechende DSPs oder sowas in einem Modem machen, das muss der Rechner dann halt selber machen, nämlich irgendwie dieses Fax-Tonsignal emulieren. Und naja, das kann man halt machen, Windows-Software unterstützt das ja auch, Windows-Kapis und so, aber das ist halt ein entsprechender Entwicklungsaufwand und da hat sich halt bei Linux bisher einfach noch niemand dran gesetzt, weil das eben einfach eine ganze Menge Arbeit ist. Hab ich noch nichts von gehört, nee.
Man ist durchaus von auszugehen, weil es eigentlich moderne Prozessoren belastet diese Modellierung nicht besonders.
Es gibt ja schon eine Modem-Emulation unter Windows, wo man ganz normales Modems und Datentranszern emulieren kann.
Das ist auch wirklich nichts Neues, das ist schon sehr lange, aber es ist irgendwie, naja, Fax. Nicht selten haben halt diese Modems, die man ja doch in der Regel noch benutzt, eh noch so ein Faxchip mit drauf oder eben auch diese Karten haben teilweise einen mit drauf oder bei den aktiven Karten haben sie das dann auch in Software realisiert.
Aber das ist schon richtig, also eigentlich will man ja halt gar kein Modem mehr einsetzen, wenn man ISDN hat, sondern möchte das halt direkt am Rechner machen, bloß wie gesagt, also für Linux hat sich da eben leider noch niemand hin gesetzt.
Aber G4-Fax zum Beispiel hat sich nie durchgesetzt.
G4-Fax, also G3-Fax ist der Standard, der heute analog ist und es gibt halt auch eine Spezifikation für ISDN. Es gibt auch G4-Fax-Geräte, aber das ist einfach mal nicht der Standard.
Da kann man ja eventuell gleich nochmal sagen, mit ISDN, das war ja sowieso eigentlich ursprünglich ganz anders gedacht, also ISDN steht ja für Integrated Services Digital Network und das war halt ursprünglich, als das mit dem Internet noch nicht so abzusehen war, wie sich das alles so entwickelt, war das halt so gedacht, dass das ISDN quasi so eine Aufgabe übernehmen sollte. Heutzutage ist es ja so, man nimmt quasi nur hauptsächlich zwei Dienste übers ISDN, war nämlich irgendwie Sprachtelefonie und halt Datenübertragung und ursprünglich war das ja so gedacht, dass man halt irgendwie jede Art von unterschiedlichen Daten darüber überträgt, also was weiß ich, Bilder, Töne in verschiedenen, also Ton in verschiedenen Qualitäten und sowas und das hat sich halt unterdicht... Genau, Bildtelefon und eben auch irgendwie ein neuer Fax-Standard, der irgendwie in Farbe und viel toller sein sollte und so. Und das ist dann halt durchs Internet, ist das halt obsolet geworden, hat sich sozusagen erübrigt.
Ja genau, zum Beispiel diese 7, 1 Kilohertz Telefonie hat sich auch nie durchgeführt.
Hat nie einer unterstützt.
Heute versucht die Telekom dann ihre ISDN Anschlüsse über andere Wege loszuwerden und den Leuten klar zu machen, warum sie unbedingt zwei Leitungen brauchen. Zum Beispiel mit ihrem Musiker und dem Malensystem, was dann auch ein sehr merkwürdiges System ist. Also einfach man versucht Gründe zu konstruieren, warum man diese zwei Leitungen braucht.
Wie ist es mit weiteren B-Kanälen? Geht auch nur, wenn man Premier-Multiplexer hat, ne?
Genau, es werden bloß halt die Varianten entweder S0 oder S2M angeboten. S0 ist eben dieses, was halt roh 144 Kilobit sind und in zwei B-Kanäle A 64K und ein D-Kanal mit 16K aufgeteilt wird. Und dann eben S2M, was halt 30 B-Kanäle A 64K sind und ein D-Kanal mit 64K noch mal dazu.
Aber dazwischen...
Dazwischen gibt es nichts. Also da gibt es dann bloß die Möglichkeit, dass du dir halt einfach mehrere S0s legen lässt.
Das ist endlich mal der Hörer, der bis dann sagt, obwohl wir uns wahrscheinlich nie im Leben treffen werden. Ich hatte noch irgendeine Zwischenfrage, die aus dem Chat kam. Dammit, das hab ich vergessen. Ah, nee, das mit dem Chat hat sich glaube ich erledigt.
Ah, hallo.
Von wo rufst du an?
Aus der Nähe Heidelberg.
Und wie hörst du Radio gerade? Und wie viel Verzögerung hast du?
So eine Sekunde oder so, keine Ahnung.
Mach mal Radio ein bisschen an, damit wir dich mal hören können.
Müssen wir jetzt was sagen?
Du musst sagen, hallo Tim.
Okay, eine Sekunde.
Wir in Baden-Württemberg sind sehr fortschrittlich.
Weil ihr so schnell Glasfasernetze in den Boden geschmissen habt?
Nie wegen dem Stromleitungsinternet. Wisst ihr was genaues drüber?
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir jetzt Protokolle runterbeeten können. Generell ist es eben so, dass sich diese Standards gerade in Entwicklung befinden. Es gibt noch nicht wirklich einen Standard, der sagt, so macht man das jetzt über Stromnetz. Sondern es gibt da verschiedene Technologien, die parallel von verschiedenen Stromherstellern gepusht werden, um über die Stromwege direkt Daten zu übertragen. Aber soweit ich gehört habe, sind die zu erzielenden Datenraten interessant genug, dass man das eigentlich haben möchte. Und eigentlich hätte man ja sowieso gerne Internet aus der Steckdose. Und damit könnte das dann auch tatsächlich was werden.
Ich bin da relativ skeptisch wegen der... Also das, was man an Informationen rüberkriegt, hängt halt an einer in Anführungsstrichen oberen Grenzfrequenz. Und gegen Hochfrequenz sind die Stromkabel alle nicht so gut geschirmt. Und wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele Kunden dann an so einer Leitung dann kommen, dann wird auch ein breiter Datenstrom, der teilt sich ja durch alle auf, geht ja doch relativ schnell in die Knie. Also da glaube ich immer noch eher, dass da über Coax-Kabel und Kabelboxen was laufen wird, als über Strom.
Wir wohnen hier ein bisschen auf dem Land, da haben wir aber keine Kabel und sowas.
Und bist du da im Einzugsgebiet von so einem Testbereich gerade?
Nein, im Moment nicht, aber ich habe einen Bekannten und der wird wahrscheinlich bald ausgeschlossen.
Also da gibt es eigentlich außer Pressemitteilung von den Stromkonzernen derzeit noch relativ wenig Erkenntnisse.
Es gibt da verschiedene Pilotprojekte. Allerdings soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, ist das Problem halt hauptsächlich, dass sich das irgendwie zwar eigentlich ganz gut anhört mit Übertragungsraten, ich glaube so bis zu... Ein Megabit, aber das Problem ist dann halt, dass du das eine Megabit eben nicht für dich alleine hast, sondern das musst du dir eben mit irgendwie im optimalsten Falle in allem mit allen zusätzlichen Mitbewohnern in deinem Wohnhaus oder Mietshaus teilen und im schlimmeren Falle mit noch mehreren.
Ja, das geht dir lieber die Getrafo halt.
Warte mal, ein Megabit mit der ganzen Straße teilen?
Ja, das kann man von der Kapazität her vergessen, weil das ist ein Megabit ist 15-mal ISDN oder 16-mal ISDN Größenordnung. Das ist in Anführungsstrichen nichts. Die Stromwerke haben schon, da wo sie die Fernkabel verlegt haben, da haben sie schon mehr gemacht, weil oben ganz auf der Spitze in dem Erdungskabel, was da bei den Hochspannungsleitungen ist, das ist in vielen Ausführungen heutzutage schon ein Stahlröhrchen, wo innen drin eine Glasfasersäle ist. Und dadurch kriegt man dann auf den Fernleitungen schon anständig Kapazität hin. Aber die Feinverteilung zu den Kunden, das ist halt das technische Problem.
Im Chat wird der Ruf nach der Frage nach Kabelmodem laut. Provider in Berlin? Kosten?
Na, es gibt hier ein Pilotprojekt von der TSS, von dieser Kabelbude hier.
Zusammen mit der, wie heißt die Wohnungsbaugesellschaft da?
Mit der WBM. Genau. Ich bin da nicht ganz up to date, wem. Ich glaube, die Netze gehörten glaube ich der WBM. Das Kabelnetz in den WBM-Wohnungen gehört sozusagen nicht der Telekom und die TSS hat, ist die eigener oder ist die nur Vertreiber von dem Netz? Ich weiß es nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall wollen die halt auch über diese Kabelfernsehwege durch Kabelmodems einen Anschluss bringen. Also wie gesagt, alle versuchen überhaupt irgendwelche letzten Meilen, die sowieso schon liegen, zu verwenden. Strom ist halt das eine, Kabelfernsehen ist das andere und Funk ist sozusagen das dritte, außer den normalen Telefonadern.
Was ist denn mit diesen Geschichten von wegen Modem zum Senden, Satellit zum Empfangen?
Ja, gibt es halt auch. Das ist allerdings normalerweise für den Privatnutzer nicht unbedingt das Sinnvollste und auch nicht das Preiswerteste. Aber da, wo du wohnst. Genau, also wenn man jetzt irgendwo mitten in der Pampa wohnt, dann kann das unter Umständen ganz gut sein. Also das basiert halt darauf, dass man eben auf der Überlegung, dass man halt selten so viel, so einen Uplink braucht in der Größenordnung, wie man halt einen Downlink braucht. Weil man eben irgendwie, man zieht sich halt hauptsächlich Daten aus dem Internet und irgendwie die paar Daten, welche Seite man jetzt gerade anklickt oder sowas, die kann man halt auch prima über eine normale Telefonleitung mit Modem oder ISDN zurückschicken. Und vom Satelliten, da kriegt man halt doch schon ganz schöne Übertragungskapazitäten hin.
Also ein Satellit lohnt nur, wenn man wirklich Bike-Downloads hat, also wirklich große Mengen. Zum Beispiel, wenn man News empfangen möchte von einem News-Server, da gibt es halt spezielle Provider, die das auch über Satellitendaunlink anbieten. Da hat man halt eine große Bandbreite und im Prinzip keine Wegekosten. Da ist das eine tolle Sache. Aber für online Internetanschluss hat Satelliten ein ganz anderes Problem, die lange Laufzeit, nämlich, die das Signal zum Satelliten und wieder zurückbrauchen. Das dauert einfach mal ein paar Sekunden. Diese Latenzzeit, also unabhängig von der Bandbreite, braucht einfach jedes Byte, egal wie viel Byte du noch parallel dazu übertragen kannst, braucht einfach eine bestimmte Zeit. Das ist natürlich in so einem interaktiven System wie dem Internet, im Web, wenn du Telnet machst oder Chat machst, hast du sozusagen immer mit jedem Zeichen immer die volle Verzögerung. Das ist auch ein Grund, warum ISDN zu bevorzugen ist gegenüber einem Modem, weil auch ein Modem eine sehr hohe Latenzzeit hat, auch wenn die schnellen Modems in der Geschwindigkeit, in der Wandbreite mittlerweile an ISDN auch ranreifen.
Satellit wäre zum Beispiel prima, wenn man halt News... Verteilkommunikation.
Für Verteilkommunikation ist es gut, für Individualkommunikation ist es wieder zu teuer und zu langsam.
Bei den Handy-Störgeräuschen fällt mir gerade ein, dass ich es zum ersten Mal ein Stück gehört hab, wo es drauf ist. Fertig schon.
Auch Faxgeräusche und Modemgeräusche waren irgendwann mal neu.
Bevor wir weitermachen, haben wir eine Frage an euch, die uns da zuhören zu Hause an den Radios. Wir würden gern von euch mal wissen, wenn ihr im Internet surft, da gibt es ja dann immer schön bei verschiedensten Programmen, bei verschiedensten Internetdiensten, kann man ja sehen, wie schnell man gerade verbunden ist bzw. wie schnell man gerade Daten sendet oder empfängt. Wir wissen gerne von euch, was ihr mit normalen Modems, also nicht über ISDN-Karte, sondern mit normalen Modems, mit welchen Modem auch immer, dass ihr dafür Geschwindigkeiten erreicht. Also was so das Schnellste ist, auf was ihr da kommt. Und dann werden wir wahrscheinlich die nächste Frage haben, wer ist der Provider und was kostet das oder irgendwie sowas. Wenn es da ein paar Ansagen gibt, so zwei, drei, vier Mal einfach so kurz hintereinander, dann reden wir nämlich weiter über das, was da an Technik alles so kommen mag. Wer ist denn da dran? Hallo?
Ja, na, hier ist Jan nochmal.
Jan nochmal.
Jetzt nicht direkt die Modemfrage leider. Ich wollte da mal kurz kommen, ihr habt ja gerade die ganzen letzten Meilen abgequatscht. Und zwar, ich glaube, ihr habt auch an eurem Newsletter was geschrieben. Standleitung, das ist jetzt zu sehr vom Thema erweichend.
Wollen wir noch zu kommen?
Dann frag doch einfach mal was.
Aber frag schon mal.
Ich habe mich auch schon öfter erkundigt, Telekom sind momentan die Einzelnen, die das machen, ne? So direkt. Und ich glaube, die wollen einen fetten Tausi Setupgebühr haben und dann...
900, 450 pro Seite.
Ja, naja gut, plus mehr stören wir auch bei Tausi.
Dann sind sie aber, also ich habe mich vor einem Jahr erkundigt, dann sind sie inzwischen sehr weit runtergegangen.
Nee, nee, also ich habe meine zum Beispiel Seite drei Jahren und habe auch nicht 900 pro Seite.
Tatsächlich, es kommt aber darauf an, wie weit du zum Provider bist.
Nee, nee, das sind dann die monatlichen Gebühren, die unterschiedlich sind.
Also die Einrichtungsgebühr hat man ja gesagt.
Die Einrichtungsgebühr geht nach den Vermittlungsstellen, die zwischen dir und dem Provider liegen.
Nein, nein, die Einrichtung ist pauschal.
Einrichtung ist pauschal, weil das ist ja irgendwie egal, auch wenn die irgendwie 500 Kilometer auseinander liegen, muss ja in beiden Vermittlungsstellen irgendwie immer das Gleiche getan werden. Naja, wenn so ein Bundespostler da erst mal in Bewegung setzt.
Ich habe die schönste Telekom-Geschichte überhaupt, die erzähle ich nachher auch noch, um richtig abzukotzen. Echt, also ich meine, das einzige Mittel, was ich habe, mich zu wehren, irgendwie ist die Tatsache, dass ich ab und zu beim Radio das Maul aufmachen darf. Die erzähle ich nachher auch noch, aber so viel dazu. Mir hat man wirklich, also ich hätte vor einem Jahr, wollte man mir verkaufen, dass ich pro Seite 4.000 Mark zahlen muss.
Für eine digitale Standleitung. 2.000 pro Seite. Ja, wir reden aber jetzt erstmal von analogen Stoßen. Also es gibt zwei verschiedene Arten, es gibt halt analoge Standleitungen, da kannst du dann an beiden Seiten ein Modem hängen, auch nicht jedes Modem, sondern das Modem muss dafür auch gerüstet sein, das sind aber die teureren Modems alle.
Also ich hab so zwei ganz billige, 150 Marksteile dran, die müssen halt irgendwie nur diese Funktion haben, dass sie die Leitung speisen können, also irgendwie AT und L1 oder L2 können wir irgendwie setzten.
Also Least Line Modus.
Least Line Modus, ja, weil du so eine ungespeiste Leitung bei Analog G bekommst, dann nennst du dich diese Leitungstyp und kosten du das Ganze, also die Telekom verlangt, je nachdem. Wenn du innerhalb der gleichen Ortsvermittlungsstelle bleibst, sind das 60 Mark plus Märchensteuer und das geht dann, glaube ich, rauf bis zu 250 Mark innerhalb des gleichen Ortsnetzes. Ja, da gibt es zum Beispiel bei in Berlin, die machen so was. Die wollen 80 Mark haben, ja. Ich bin eigentlich ganz zufrieden damit.
Ja, ja, hab ich auch schon mal angedacht. Aber ich hab's dann doch gelassen, weil mir 250 bis 80, da haben wir dann doch noch etwas.
Na ja, es kommt drauf an, wo du wohnst.
Ja, ich wohn ganz weit draußen. Also 250 sind auf jeden Fall, ich wohn in Klare und ich glaub, die nächste in Berlin ist irgendwo Dahlheim oder so. Bei mir hab ich...
Nee?
Also ich hab's, glaub ich, vom halben Jahr mal gerechnet, da waren es immer noch maximal. Ab dann wird's nicht teurer, oder?
Aber auf jeden Fall. Es ist schon teurer, aber ich meine, wenn man wirklich viel Internet macht, dann ist eine Standleitung schon zu erwägen. Also ich komm locker über 250 Mark Telefongebühren.
Ja, ich wäge gerade so um 210.
Und da muss man halt sehen, wenn man irgendwie eine Standleitung hat, hat man natürlich auch gleich eine ganz andere Qualität. Das ist ja... Dial-up hat immer das Problem nur krasst. Jedes Mal eine neue IP-Nummer. Und du musst dann irgendwie auch den PPP-Krempel halt auf deinem Rechner laufen lassen. Und eigentlich möchte man das ja ganz lieber ganz elegant über Ethernet machen und auch mit mehreren Rechnern ran. Und vor allem, wenn man eine Standleitung hat, hat man ja eine feste IP-Adresse und kann dann eben auch Server fahren. Hat halt einfach sein System die ganze Zeit online. Und wenn man irgendwo anders ist, kann man jederzeit auf seine privaten Daten zurückgreifen, wenn man das durch so eingerichtet hat und das möchte. Und kann halt einen eigenen Web-Server fahren. Der kann dann zwar nicht besonders viel leisten, aber für eine Homepage ist das völlig ausreichend.
Das kam ich um Weihnachten als Mobilkonto an. Da hat sich auch mal ein Linux-Servernacht über dran hängen, aber das sind wir auch.
Aber da rennen wir von analogen Standleitungen, das heißt du kannst höchstens mit einem V90-Modern dann daran.
Nee, V90 ist ja nicht... Analog, ist ja komplett analog.
Genau, allerdings gibt es da jetzt irgendwie einen ganz netten...
Wenigstens beschwult allerdings. Früher habe ich irgendwie gehört, dass du auch irgendwie irgendwas digital drauf fahren konntest.
Du konntest da ISDN simulieren drauf. Weil du hattest ja wirklich zwei Drähte. Du hattest auf der einen Seite eine Batterie angeschlossen und auf der anderen Seite ein Lämpchen. Und dann hat auf der anderen Seite dieses Lämpchen gekippt.
Inzwischen gibt es allerdings da wieder ein ganz interessanter Antrieb. Und zwar gibt es jetzt... Also die Telekom macht das jetzt zunehmend so, dass sie halt keine wirklich analogen Standleitungen mehr verlegt, wenn du eine analoge Standleitung haben möchtest. Sondern es gibt jetzt die sogenannten digital geführten analogen Standleitungen. Das heißt, du hast tatsächlich eine digitale Leitung zu dir nach Hause liegen. Und zu Hause schrauben die dir dann halt ein Gerät dran, was das wieder nach analog wandelt. Und der Trick besteht jetzt einfach darin, du schraubst halt auf beiden Seiten dieses Umwandeldevice wieder ab und schraubst halt einfach ISDN-NTBAs dran. Und dann hast du halt einfach eine 1A-ISDN-Standleitung zum Analogpreis.
Mit 64 Kbps?
Mit 144 Kbps.
Also eigentlich ja 144 kannst du sagen.
Also du kannst halt dann tatsächlich direkt den UK0 voll ausnutzen und hast dann eine 144 Kbps-Standleitung. Allerdings ist das halt noch nicht überall so. Aber ich weiß, aus Hamburg, aus bestimmten Bereichen, da wird das jetzt nur noch so gemacht.
In Berlin ist das auch so.
Kann die Telekom sowas nicht feststellen?
Das sind die rein analogen Leitungen.
Das sind die analogen Leitungen. Da ist es tatsächlich wirklich so. Aber bei einer digitalen Leitung kannst du natürlich irgendwie keine Spuren dazwischen schalten.
Das ist die Frage, ob sie sich draufklemmen und dann irgendwie bei ihr vorbeikommen. Aber die sollen sich auch mal ein bisschen an die Füße fassen. Was die da machen mit ihrer Preispolitik, das brennt einfach an Wegelagerei. Nein, das ist Wegelagerei. Wir haben hier irgendwie den Fluss und ihr wollt da durchfahren und ihr spannt einfach mal eine Kette drüber, wenn ich dicke Goldbarren auf den Tisch lege. Dann seid ihr einfach mal draußen. Das muss auch ein Ende finden. Und ich meine, so Mobilecom, wo du das gerade erwähnst, die haben halt diesen Pauschaltarif gemacht, da hat man zwar dial-up, aber man hätte ja im Prinzip, man hat ja von denen sozusagen die Aussage bekommen, egal wie lange du drin bist, du zahlst halt nur maximal 77 Mark, wenn du das nur in den Nebentarifzeiten irgendwie verwendest. Das hat natürlich alles nicht funktioniert, weil sich offenbart hat, dass MogelCom nichts anderes ist als ein Marketingladen mit einer großen Klappe, die alles dafür taten, Schlagzeilen zu bekommen. Das ist ja dann auch gelungen.
Na ja, ganz so würde ich das nicht sehen. MogelCom macht wirklich viele Sachen, die fraglich sind. Insbesondere bei der Abrechnung kommen da echt viele Sachen durcheinander, aber sie sind teilweise auch ziemlich innovativ.
Sie sind sehr innovativ bei ihren allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen.
Sie waren echt einfach mal die ersten, die sich so etwas überhaupt getraut haben. Das ist leider völlig in die Hose gegangen, weil sie einfach nicht damit gerechnet haben, dass jeder, der in Deutschland Internet benutzt, jetzt diesen Tarif haben will.
Ich finde, da kommen verschiedene Sachen zusammen. Wenn wir nur über Mobilecom reden, dann müssen wir auch über Tomorrow reden, über Fragesgruppe Mildstraße, die damit auch gut Promo für sich gemacht haben und damit groß geworben haben auf der Zeitung. Und in den allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen gleich klein gedruckten Abo mit verkauft haben. Das sind alles schon Sachen, wo ich zum Beispiel finde, dass als sich der Verbraucherschutz eingeschaltet hat, das durchaus berechtigt war, dass man dann auf den Verbraucherschutz stürmt und sagt, ihr Schweine nehmt uns unseren billigen...
Ne, das finde ich überhaupt nicht okay, dass sie auf den Verbraucherschutz reingegangen sind.
Definitiv nicht.
Da sind irgendwie Leute echt zu schnell, wenn sie die Seiten vom Verbraucherschutz hacken und sagen, ihr Schweine nehmt uns unseren billigen Internetzugang weg. Das ist echt kurz...
Das war überhaupt die Frechheit. Das Mobil kommen sie auch noch dahin stellen und sagen, der blöde Verbraucherschutz und so. Ich weiß, wir sollen uns jetzt auch noch an die Regeln halten und was wir sollen, den Dienst, den wir verkauft haben, sondern auch noch ein halbes Jahr.
Sie haben einfach gemerkt, es geht nicht. Sie haben gemerkt, es geht so nicht, wie wir... Genau. Und sie wollten jetzt irgendwie rauskommen aus der Sache. Und da kam ihnen natürlich... Die Sache vom Verbraucherschutz kam ihnen echt gerade richtig passend.
Sehr schlecht.
Aber was ich noch gehört habe, momentan mit den Abrechtungen über Call by Call, soll es irgendwie geben, wenn man seine Telekom-Rechnung sich nicht per Bankerzug machen lässt, sondern per Überweisung, dann kann man die Beträge, die man über Call by Call führt, einfach nicht mit überweisen. Und die Telekom mahnt es nicht an, weil die Telekom sagt, es interessiert mich nicht. Und die Call by Call-Anbieter sollen es irgendwie nicht nachvollziehen können, wenn es welche sind, wo man sich nicht anmelden muss, können die nicht genau nachvollziehen, wer welche Kosten verursacht hatten, können es auch nicht mahnen, sodass man im Endeffekt nichts bezahlt für die Call by Call.
Das haben wir aber erst mal vorher probiert, dass es dann nicht spiegelt.
Also die Sache ist tatsächlich wohl die, dass es im Augenblick halt so ist, weil es ursprünglich gedacht war, kleiner 50 Mark Beträge werden halt nicht angemahnt, weil das dann halt auch die Telekom machen müsste. Und die haben gesagt, das wird uns zu teuer, das machen wir nicht. Allerdings ist es so, wie man das jetzt hört, es ist wohl durchaus so, dass die nachvollziehen können, also wo das herkommt. Ich meine, es ist auch so, dass die Call-by-Call-Betreiber übermitteln ja die Verbindungsdaten und die Rechnungsdaten an die Telekom. Das heißt, die müssen schon wissen irgendwie, wer wieviel telefoniert hat und so. Und das soll jetzt wohl also nachträglich alles eingefordert werden.
Ich habe es nur so gehört, und da gab es auch ganz viele tolle Seiten wieder, die versprochen haben, klickt diese Tausend-Bänner an und dann gebe ich euch eine Ratte, wie man alles kostenlos machen kann.
Das die Wärmer wohl nicht loswerden, diese Dinger.
Schickt mir 500 Mark und ich schreibe euch einen Brief.
Ich glaube früher hieß das einfach, schicken sie mir 5 Mark einen Briefmark und ich sage ihnen, wie sie reich werden.
Genau.
Ungefähr dasselbe System.
Ja, inzwischen wollen sie 500 Mark hauen.
Ja klar, aber nicht in Briefmark. Ich danke dir erstmal.
Ja, bis dann.
Tja, Standleitung, das ist das, was man eigentlich haben will. Also diese ganze Dial-Up-Geschichte ist total akkrat.
Weil es eine völlig andere Qualität ist. Ich kann mich da irgendwie immer hinsetzen, wenn ich möchte. Ich muss ja kein schlechtes Gewissen haben, dass irgendwie jetzt 5 Mark die Stunde an die Telefonen drücken muss.
Da können wir ja vielleicht gleich nochmal zu ADSL kommen. Irgendwie sozusagen, was zukünftige Verbindungsmöglichkeiten angeht.
Das sind so kurz vorher mal, wir haben jetzt gerade so ein paar Preise gehört für analoge Standleitungen. Wie liegen die dann bei ISDN?
ISDN-Standleitungen?
Naja, zweimal 2000 Mark pro Seite.
Also das sind die Einrichtungsgebühren. Und dann pro Monat, ich glaube...
300 irgendwas? Ach, früher gab es ja noch die semi-permanente Verbindung.
Ja, früher gab es das. Als ISDN noch mit 1 TR6 und nicht mit DSS1 lief, dann gab es halt die sogenannte semi-permanente Verbindung. Das war eigentlich was super Cooles. Das sollten sie auch wieder einführen, das haben sie aber sein gelassen, weil sie gesehen haben, dass wenn sie es weglassen, dass sie damit mehr Geld verdienen können. Sodass man im Prinzip gesagt hat, ich benutze das wie eine normale Leitung, rufe da also an, aber ich zahle halt einen festen Betrag für die Verbindung zu diesem Teilnehmer, sodass man im Prinzip eine Standleitung hat, auch wenn man sie technisch benutzt, wie eine normale Dial-up Leitung. Das war eigentlich das, was man haben wollte. Das kam auch zu einem relativ seriösen Preis. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie er war, aber war alles sehr...
Keine Setupgebühren.
Ja genau, da war es halt keine weiteren Verbindungsgebühren. Man hat halt einen fixen Betrag bezahlt und das haben sie dann aber irgendwie mit der Umstellung auf Euro-ISDN haben sie das feilen lassen, weil ihnen das halt sozusagen billig war.
Und es gibt bei den Leuten, die über eine ISDN-Standleitung nachdenken, sollte man vielleicht auch noch sagen, dass es da noch eine Fußange gibt, denn die Telekom versucht einem natürlich Rabatte zu verkaufen. Diese Rabatte sind gebunden an eine bestimmte Vertragslänge. Das heißt, Telekom versucht also, du weißt ja nicht, zwei ISDN-Kanäle an dich zu verkaufen und sagt, wenn du das für zwei Jahre machst, dann kriegst du an einmal 10 oder 15 oder 20% auf die Gesamtsumme, die übrigens sehr viel höher ist als 300 Mark. Ich hab liegt bei 800 oder so. Also es ist schon so, dass man sich fragen muss, ob das sich noch die Waage hält, speziell mit den Einrichtungsgebühren.
Ja, und man braucht auch einen Provider, der einem sozusagen das bietet, dass es derzeit nicht gang und gäbe.
Und mit diesen Rabatten muss man extrem vorsichtig sein, weil was in einem Jahr ist oder gar in zwei Jahren, das steht in den Sternen bzw. nicht so sehr in den Sternen, das kann man sich halbwegs ausrechnen. Und wenn man dann noch mit einer 144 Kilobit-Standleitung da steht, die man bezahlen muss, also wenn man diesen Vertrag unterschrieben hat, dann ist man wirklich auf diese zwei Jahre gebunden, dann hat man wahrscheinlich gelust.
Also ich denke, es wird sich einiges tun, auch weil es gibt ja wie gesagt noch diese andere Anschlussmöglichkeit über Funk. Da wird gerade viel experimentiert, auch bei Internet-Service-Provideren oder vor allem bei Internet-Service-Provideren. Es gibt diesen schönen Standard IEEE 802.11. Das kann man schon raushören, Ethernet ist 802.3 und 802.11 ist sozusagen Ethernet über Funk. Das funktioniert so, dass man einen Access Point hat, also einen zentralen Verteiler, und dann kann man eben mit mobilen Stations, sprich Laptop, mit einer kleinen PC Card drin, mit einer Antenne dran, kann man irgendwie im Umkreis von zwei Kilometern durch die Gegend laufen und so wie das bei Ethernet funktioniert, Datenpakete in die Luft schmeißen. Also das Ethernet-Kabel ist sozusagen im Luftraum gespannt und auch das wird, ich prophezeihe, relativ bald, wobei bald kann schon noch ein Jahr dauern, wird es das geben. Und wann es bezahlbar wird, wird es noch nicht so ganz abschätzbar. Derzeit kostet das Equipment klein, glaube ich, 1500 Mark und dann für diesen Access Point auch nochmal 1500 Mark. Also es ist noch etwas teuer, aber das kann sich halt schnell legen. Damit kann man eben nicht nur ohne die Telekom eine Verbindung machen, sondern man hat auch noch gleich Mobil-Internet, kann also im Prinzip mit seinem Gerät durch die Gegend marschieren. San Francisco ist das Gang und Gebe, da haben sie alle ihre kleinen Palm-Pilots und unter dem Palm-Pilot noch so ein Ricochet-Modem, das Ding ist auch nur irgendwie flach, sieht aus wie ein Extra-Batterie-Pack, noch eine Antenne dran und dann hat man da 32 Kilobit Internet-Standleitung über Funk.
Für 20 Dollar übrigens im Monat.
Für 20 Dollar, hört euch das mal an, ist doch unglaublich, oder?
Ich bewege mich. Und dann werde ich, bevor wir jetzt gleich zum Kurzinfo kommen, werde ich jetzt auch noch mal eine blöde Telekom-Geschichte, wo ich meine Hassgeschichte habe. Mir ist in den letzten Tagen was passiert, was bisher, ich bin glaube ich seit 19 Jahren, glaube ich, habe ich einen eigenen Telefonanschluss. Ist mir bisher noch nicht passiert. Ich habe mit der Firma zwei ISDN-Anschlüsse, habe jetzt noch einen ganz normalen Basisanschluss dazubestellt und weil ich mal auf eine Telekom-Rechnung eine Mahnung bekommen habe, die erst dann bezahlt wurde, habe ich jetzt von der Telekom eine Schreibung gekriegt, dass in meinem dritten Telefonanschluss, und dazu kann man vielleicht auch noch sagen, dass der Telefongebühren von etwa 1000 Mark im Monat anfallen in dieser Firma, dass für diesen dritten Telefonanschluss eine Kaution von 500 Mark zu hinterlegen, sei aus Sicherheitsgründen, denn ich wäre einmal in Verzug geraten. Und da das in den Unterlagen ist, müsste man jetzt also eine Kaution nehmen, bevor man mir noch einen Telefonanschluss legen kann. Der zuständige Mensch, mit dem ich da gesprochen habe, hat mir dann auch gesagt, das stünde irgendwo in den allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen. Das wird dann wahrscheinlich auch so sein. Und das Schöne an diesen 500 Mark, die ich da jetzt hinterlegen soll, bevor ich meinen weiteren Telefonanschluss kriege, ist außerdem, dass die frühestens nach neun Monaten verrechnet werden. Das heißt, ich gebe der Telekom einen 500 Mark Kredit über neun Monate, der natürlich ausdrücklich, und das steht in dem Schreiben ausdrücklich drin, nicht verzinst wird. Und der wird auch nur dann verrechnet nach frühestens neun Monaten, wenn bis dahin auf keiner der Anschlüsse, die unter meinem Namen laufen, irgendein Verzug in Kraft getreten ist. Also wenn ich jede Rechnung wirklich sofort bezahlt habe. Und das hat mich echt was gekostet, vorgestern da nicht komplett auszurasten. Das war echt richtig hart. So was habe ich bisher noch nicht erlebt.
Klingt so ein bisschen nach Beugehaft. Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich da mache. Mal gucken.
So viel also aus dem Privatdame des Johnny H.
Protest. China hat im Welt-Sicherheitsrat ein Ende der US-Luftangriffe auf den Irak verlangt. Sonst könnten die humanitären Programme der UNO nicht greifen. Zuvor hatte bereits die Türkei die Einstellung der Bombardements gefordert. Dabei war eine Ölpipeline zerstört worden. Einspruch. Kurz vor der geplanten Hinrichtung des Deutsch-Amerikaners Lagran hat ein Berufungsgericht in den USA einen Aufschub verfügt. Der Bundesstaat Arizona kündigte sofort eine Gegenklage an. Das Todesurteil gegen Lagran wegen Raubmordes sollte in der Nacht vollzogen werden. Ökosteuer. Der Bundestag hat die Gesetzesvorlage angenommen. Danach sollen zum 1. April die Benzin- und Energiepreise erhöht und die Beiträge zur Rentenversicherung gesenkt werden. Dem Gesetz muss noch der Bundesrat zustimmen. Konflikt. Ein serbischer Polizist ist am Abend in Kosovo getötet worden. Nach Angaben aus Pristina starte er bei einem Anschlag albanischer Separatisten. Entscheidung. Israel hat eine Blockade der Palästinenser Gebiete aufgehoben. Der Gazastreifen und das Westjordanland waren aus furchtbar Anschlägen, während jüdischer Feiertage mehrere Tage abgeriegelt worden. Die Palästinenser nannten dies einen Verstoß gegen die Friedensverträge. Fußball im Viertelfilale der Champions League gewann Bayern München gegen Kaiserslautern 2 zu 0. Heute gelegentlich Schauer 10 bis 14 Grad. Verkehr. Uns liegen immer noch keine aktuellen Verkehrsmeldungen vor, war trotzdem weiter schön vorsichtig.
Fachproblemgruppe, für verschiedenste Sachen gibt es ja unterschiedliche Gründe und ich will jetzt einen anderen Grund für eine verschiedene Sache nennen und die Sache selbst ist die, dass ich am 5. März in der Volksbühne am Rosa-Luxemburg-Platz um 21 Uhr wieder einen Videoschnipsel-Vortrag machen werde und dass man dahin gehen sollte. Nur, dass mir der Grund jetzt nicht direkt einfällt, aber das ist wie immer volle Bombenstimmung, prima Party, man sitzt eng beieinander und...
Kurtner trägt Videoschnipsel vor. Freitag, 5. März in der Volksbühne Berlin. Trotzdem, präsentiert von Fritz.
Und genau dort hört ihr weiterhin das Chaosradio noch bis 1 Uhr. Dann gibt's den Night Flight mit Martin Petersdorf. Chaosradio heute mit der Musik von Agent Me. Live-Aufnahmen von zwei Menschen, die gute Musik machen. Das Thema Inhaltlich sind Netzzugangstechnologien und jetzt haben wir noch 25 Minuten mit anderen Worten. Wir werden es mit der Zukunft beschäftigen.
ADSL.
Wann kommt's? Was kostet's?
Wie schnell ist es?
Naja, also es ist irgendwie eigentlich schon relativ schnell, also deutlich mehr in die Richtung, wie man das eigentlich haben möchte. Es kommt dieses Jahr von der Telekom und es ist einfach unbezahlbar teuer. Naja, das heißt, dass die Telekom sich jetzt überlegt... ADSL kann man erst mal sagen, ist sozusagen, nachdem die Amis irgendwie das mit dem ISDN nie so richtig hingekriegt haben und irgendwie 64 Kb, sind wir 128 Kb, der sowieso nicht mehr so state of the art sind, hat man sich halt ADSL überlegt, was eben ermöglicht, über kurze Distanzen, was heißt irgendwie, dass die letzte Meide nicht länger sein darf, als so 5, 6 km, halt ziemlich hohe Übertragungsraten, also das, was man früher eigentlich für unmöglich gehalten hätte, über den einfachen Kupferdraht hinkriegt.
Über zwei oder vier?
Zwei. Genau. Und das heißt irgendwie konkret, also ADSL heißt Downstream 8 Megabit, also von der anderen Seite zu dir halt 8 Megabit und Upstream 1, 5 Megabit.
Wie schnell sind denn im Vergleich T1 und T3 bei den Amis?
Also T1 sind 1, 54 Megabit. Also da hat man dann, das ist das Qualität. T3 sind 44, 7 Megabit, wenn ich mich recht erinnere.
Das ist so unglaublich, wenn man das benutzt.
Ja, das ist wirklich richtig schnell. Und vor allen Dingen der Witz ist in den USA, ich meine T3 hast du nicht unbedingt zu Hause liegen, aber T3 irgendwie im Büro ist eine ganz normale Sache einfach. Und hier freut man sich über, yes, 256 Kilometer.
Ich habe eine T3-Leitung, Standleitung, hat mir neulich jemand erzählt, würde so um die 3000 Dollar kosten. Also wir reden jetzt von Büros, wo weiß ich nicht, wie viele Rechner im Netz hängen und die alle Zugriff haben, aber 44 Megabit sind ein Hammer. Also wäre da jemals irgendwie, das ist einfach unglaublich.
Ja, das muss das sein.
Genau, naja und jetzt halt damit man irgendwie diese Geschwindigkeiten auch annähernd nach Hause bringen kann, gibt es dann jetzt eben ADSL. Auch in einer, also die Variante, die jetzt erstmal hauptsächlich am Anfang zur Verfügung stehen wird, ist ADSL Lite oder auch G-Lite genannt, was halt downstream 1, 5 Megabit bietet und upstream 128 Kilobit, wenn ich mich recht erinnere und das ist auch einfacher zu machen, wenn die letzte Meile länger ist, weil da halt die Anforderungen an den Drahten nicht ganz so hoch sind. Na ja und das ist eben so, also ADSL darf man jetzt nicht als Ersatz für irgendwie ISDN oder normale Telefonleitung sehen, weil halt ADSL ist quasi einfach eine Standleitung zu deiner nächsten Vermittlungsstelle und da muss es dann eben einen Anschluss an den Datendienst, den du darüber nutzen möchtest, was halt im Allgemeinen das Internet ist, geben. Und Telefonleitung kann man weiterhin, also braucht man halt weiterhin, man kann entweder analoge Telefonleitung oder auch ISDN ganz normal trotzdem weiterhin über diesen über diesen Kupferdraht halt über denselben Kupferdraht bestehen haben, weil das in einem ganz anderen Frequenzbereich liegt. Also die beiden Dienste stören sich da nicht gegenseitig.
Wo versteht denn ADSL eigentlich?
Asymmetric Digital Subscriber Line. Und das Problem ist halt erstens, dass die Telekom natürlich sich am Anfang erst mal gedacht hat, oh prima, das geht in unsere Vermittlungsstellen und die wollen alle Internet haben. Und wir haben noch da diesen schicken Internetdienst, T-Online, und dann drücken wir denen halt allen T-Online aufs Auge. Wer ADSL haben will, muss halt auch T-Online machen. Das ist jetzt irgendwie, nachdem es da herbe Proteste von Seiten der anderen Anbieter gab, ist das jetzt irgendwie mal ganz schnell revidiert worden. Und es wurde gesagt, nein, natürlich können auch alle anderen Internet-Service-Provider dazu Zugang erhalten. Sollte man dann noch sehen, in welchem Maße das tatsächlich verwirklicht wird. Ansonsten, die Preise für ADSL-Leitungen sind erst mal irgendwie wirklich astronomisch. Und zwar werden die halt wieder zeitbasiert abgerechnet. Und das soll am Anfang sein, dass du für 25 Stunden Onlinezeit 250 Mark zahlst. Also quasi irgendwie eine Stunde kostet irgendwie 10 Mark. So und jede weitere Stunde soll halt 8 Mark kosten. Und die Telekom hat das halt damit begründet, dass sie die ISDN-Nachfrage nicht stören wollen. Das heißt, sie wollen nicht irgendwie, dass jetzt alle plötzlich ganz schnell schnell das Internet haben wollen, sondern sie möchten halt weiterhin ihre schönen ISDN-Kanäle verkaufen, weil ihnen das halt letztlich irgendwie deutlich größere Einnahmen sichert. Und möchten halt ADSL erst mal nur so nach dem Motto, ja wir können das halt und sie möchten da halt auch sicherstellen, dass sie da technisch irgendwie Ahnung davon haben, dadurch, dass sie das halt überhaupt machen und da Erfahrungen mitsammeln, aber sie wollen das halt, sie machen das halt so teuer, dass sich das im Massenmarkt quasi erst mal gar nicht durchsetzen kann. Im Gegensatz zu zum Beispiel in den USA, wo du halt irgendwie ADSL-Access kriegst du halt so für, naja, so pauschal 40 Dollar im Monat oder sowas. Also es ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich, aber so in der Größenordnung bewegt sich das.
Die Sache, die ich am Anfang erzählt habe, über die Rationalisierung in den 60er Jahren, bekommt hier eine hochinteressante Bedeutung, denn dadurch, dass im Weltdurchschnitt die letzte Meile in Deutschland relativ kurz ist, kriegt man dort relativ hohe Bitraten rüber genagelt und das heißt wiederum, wenn man sagt, Telekom, ich will die letzten zwei Drähte von meiner Hütte bis zur Vermittlungsstelle einfach für mich exklusiv und da kommt dann der Provider dran, der mich interessiert und was zwischen dem Provider und mir technisch funktioniert, geht dich nichts mehr an. Das ist das, was ich in der Zukunft sehe.
So, wir wollen jetzt die wenigen Minuten, die wir noch haben, nutzen, damit ihr auf alle Fälle noch Fragen stellen könnt. Die Nummer hier ist 0331 für Potsdam, 7097110. Am besten wäre das, wenn ihr wirklich anruft, sagt das und das wollte ich noch wissen und dann raus aus der Leitung, Frage wird beantwortet und der nächste oder die nächste, dann schaffen wir das noch alles. Vielleicht zwei, drei Sätze noch zum Thema GSM im Moment, 9600.
Genau, im Augenblick gibt es da relativ langsame, da haben wir gerade sehr schön GSM, sind halt im Augenblick 9600 Bit pro Sekunde, was irgendwie alles andere als berauschend ist. In diesem Jahr wird halt eingeführt werden HSCSD, was für High Speed Circuit Switch Data steht. Können wir das jetzt eventuell noch mal disablen?
Ich habe neulich jemanden gehabt, der vor meinem nicht gerade kleinen CD-Regal stand und ein CD gesucht hat und die ganze Zeit schrie Apfel F, Apfel F.
Okay, genau, so, HSCSD, also was wie gesagt für High Speed Circuit Switch Data steht, wird dann tatsächlich unglaubliche 14400 Bit pro Sekunde unterstützen. Genau, das kommt halt irgendwie dieses Jahr noch und wird mit ganz normalen irgendwie den neuen jetzt auf der CeBIT vorgestellten GSM-Telefonen, von denen wird das halt unterstützt werden. Die Netzbetreiber werden das jetzt halt auch nachrüsten. Aber was wir halt wirklich wollen ist GPRS, was für General Packet Radio System steht, was halt schon so ein kleiner Vorgeschmack auf das kommende UMTS, also der GSM-Nachfolger ist, was halt jetzt in der Anfangsphase, also ist halt erstmal Paketvermittelte Datenübertragung in GSM. Das bietet jetzt halt in der Anfangsphase Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit von bis zu 115 Kilobit pro Sekunde. Und das ist ja dann doch schon mal deutlich mehr in der Richtung, wie man das eigentlich haben möchte.
Soviel dann kurz zum Thema GSM. Wer ist da am Telefon?
Ich wollte fragen, als es anfing mit der, also dass mehrere Anbieter auf den Markt kommen, Telefon, da hieß es glaube ich auch, dass die Anbieter irgendwann selber auch den Anschluss ins Haus legen kommen. Ist das denn irgendwie falsch verstanden?
Nee, das ist überhaupt nicht falsch verstanden. Das Problem ist bloß, dass es halt einfach verdammt teuer ist. Also du musst dir halt vorstellen, was da alles dazu gehört. Du musst halt irgendwie die Straße aufreißen und musst da halt Kabel reinschmeißen und musst die Kabel halt in die Häuser legen und so was. Genau, die Telekom hat das alles schon prima mit Steuergeldern damals von Bundespost-Zeiten finanziert, da schon liegen.
Mit Kundengeldern, die Telekom oder die Bundespost war die Geldkuh und hat riesige Mengen abgeführt an den Staatshaushalt, so rum. Mit Kundengeldern. Das haben wir Bürger bezahlt.
Das ist ein enormer Kostenaufwand, deshalb machen das nur ganz wenige Anbieter. Also Coil Telekom zum Beispiel, die in den großen Städten überall ihre eigenen Glasfaserringe legen und bieten ausschließlich für Geschäftskunden Services an. Was ansonsten angedacht ist, ist die letzte Meile per Funk zu machen. Da gab es verschiedene Versuche, allerdings war das alles unbefriedigend, dass das jetzt auch erstmal so auf Eis liegt und man sich da ein bisschen nach neuen Möglichkeiten umguckt. Und im Augenblick sieht es halt tatsächlich so aus, dass zumindest was wir dieses Jahr zu sehen kriegen, wird halt nur das sein, was halt die Anbieter über die letzte Meile zustande bringen, die sie halt von der Telekom für diese 25 Mark 50, die da beschlossen wurden, zustande bringen.
Wenn ich jetzt, also ich hab vor für viel mit mir eventuell den nächsten Computer zu kaufen und dann auch mit Internetzugang, hab aber so gut wie keine Ahnung davon und wo kann ich denn da Informationen mehr kriegen?
Bei einer der 28 Zeitschriften, die auf dem Markt sind?
Nein, ja nur bei einer.
Verstehe mich nicht falsch, aber wie mit allen Sachen, die man anfängt, muss man sich natürlich irgendwie einarbeiten und einlesen. Und ich meine, zum Thema Internet und Computer gehst du in irgendeine Zeitschriftenladung und da findest du garantiert massig Material für Einsteiger. Es gibt jeder etwas anständige Buchladen, hat eine eigene Abteilung für das Thema. Ich glaube, die Frage übrigst dich mit Lesen.
Na ja, kauf dir einen Mac, kauf dir den ISDN-Modern.
Ja, kauf dir keinen Mac.
Okay, danke, tschüss.
Warum nicht?
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, ich bin der Toni. Ja, erstmal meine Modemgeschwindigkeit ist da so 3, 3 bis 3, 5K und ich hänge an der TU seit 92 ungefähr. Ja, ich wollte noch so ein Beispiel bringen, weil ich von einem Editor eines Online-Magazins gelesen habe, der sich einen ADSL-Anschluss bestellt hat, ungefähr zwei Monaten. Und der hat für eine 128kW-Upload, 384-Download bezahlt er 60 Dollar im Monat.
Also wie gesagt, in den USA ist das nicht wirklich ein Thema. Und hier zeigt man sich dafür dumm und dämlich.
Und man kann gleichzeitig auch noch normale Ortsgespräche hören.
Man muss vielleicht auch mal dazu sagen, dass wenn man jetzt sagt, in den USA ist das alles so günstig und kein Thema und so. Das hat natürlich auch eine ganz kapitalistische Ursache, warum das so ist. Und das ist ja auch das, was viele Firmen hier in Deutschland bemängeln, denn Geschichten wie das, wovon viele so gerne reden, nämlich E-Commerce zum Beispiel, stoppt man natürlich einfach durch solche Preispolitik, wie wir sie haben in Deutschland. Also die schöne große kapitalistische Welt des Online-Einkaufens, werden wir so garantiert nie haben. Wir werden auch so nie ein Online-Radio haben oder Online-Fernsehsender, wenn das nach wie vor einfach unerschwindlich ist und die Amis senken oder haben deswegen so niedrige Preise, weil sie einfach hoffen, dass dieses Geld über andere Kanäle wieder reinkommt.
Weil sie auch einfach einen liberalisierteren Markt haben. Ich meine, in Deutschland haben wir einfach de facto nach wie vor dasselbe Monopol wie vor zehn Jahren. Solange es angehen kann, dass die Telekom-Leitung, die sie nicht selber bezahlt hat, den anderen Anbietern teurer überlässt als ihren eigenen Kunden. So ist nämlich der Fakt derzeit. Solange kann sich da nichts dran tun. Es liegt daran, dass 50 Prozent der Telekom der Bundesregierung gehören und die keine Kohle haben will.
Es liegt ganz eindeutig an der Politik. Aus der kapitalistischen Sicht gesehen, wenn ich die Telekom wäre, ich würde das ganz genauso machen, wie es die Telekom auch tut. Das Problem ist, dass sowas reguliert werden muss. Und zwar eigentlich noch stärker. Man hat das jetzt gesehen beim Markt für Ferngespräche, was sich da innerhalb eines Jahres getan hat. Jetzt ist es zu jeder Tages- und Nachtzeit möglich für maximal ein Pfennig mehr als ein Ortsgespräch, die Minute kostet, ein Ferngespräch zu führen. Und die tagsüber kostet ein Ortsgespräch acht Pfennig die Minute. Und man kann ab neun Pfennig die Minute Ferngespräche führen. Das muss man sich halt einfach mal überlegen. Und Ortsgespräche, das irgendwie die... Also es ist nicht so, dass Ferngespräche jetzt im internationalen Vergleich so unglaublich billig bei uns wären, sondern es ist halt einfach so, dass es deshalb so nah zusammen gerückt, weil Ortsgespräche immer noch so unglaublich teuer bei uns sind. Einfach dadurch, dass die Telekom eben durch diese Letzte-Meilen-Politik irgendwie da immer noch das Monopol hat.
Zum Thema Politik, vielleicht noch die Anmerkung. Wie heißt dieser Multimedia-Abgeordnete von der SPD? Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher. Jedenfalls ist es in einem neuen Debug, eine sowieso sehr lobenswerte Zeitschrift, ein kurzes Statement dazu drin. Und da gibt es dieses Zitat von ihm, wo er gesagt hat irgendwie, E-Mail und Internet wird in Zukunft so selbstverständlich sein, wie das Telefonieren aus einer Telefonzelle, wo Debug dann sehr charmant, finde ich, kommentiert, dass, abgesehen davon, dass das eine Allgemeinweisheit ist, die man auch in einer Bäckerblume finden kann, dass man sich doch fragt, ob der Mann kein Handy hat.
Aber Telefonieren in der Telefonzelle ist heute geworden.
Genau, gerade am Montag.
Gibt es da noch Telefonzellen, wo man Geld reinschmeißt?
Ich habe noch keins gesehen hier in Berlin. Nur einen sehr abgelegenen Winkel.
Extrem ärgerlich, finde ich. Denn wenn man mal eine Telefonzelle braucht, dann hat man garantiert keine Telefonkarte dabei. Gut, aber lassen wir am Rande. Ich danke dir.
Wenn du ein Telefon brauchst, kannst du ja mittlerweile zum erstbesten Teenager laufen, der über die Straße hoppst. Dann haben ja meistens alle schon eine im Stiefel.
Das stimmt. Ich würde vorschlagen, dass wir die Sendung rechtzeitig beenden.
Meinst du wirklich?
7 Minuten ist nicht so richtig viel Zeit, aber dann kann sich Martin vielleicht mal in Ruhe auf den Night Flight einrichten.
Wolltest du nicht eigentlich noch was zu RC5 erzählen?
Das wäre ein schöner Abschluss, vielleicht noch sozusagen auf jeden zu weisen. Wir haben es ja schon letztes Mal erwähnt, wir nehmen an dem RC5 64 Cracking Contest teil.
Das ist immer noch nicht vorbei?
Das wird noch eine Weile dauern. Da wird seit einem 1, 5 Jahr gerechnet. Bei der aktuellen Keyrate würde es theoretisch auch noch 10 Jahre dauern. Nur, dass die Keyrate natürlich am laufenden Meter hoch geht, weil die Computer schneller werden und natürlich auch immer mehr daran teilnehmen. Es ist schon davon auszugehen, dass es noch ein Jahr läuft, kann aber auch morgen schon vorbei sein, wenn der Key gefunden wird. Das Schöne an dem Spiel ist, dass man sich primar zu einem Team zusammenschließen kann und dann in einer Statistik immer schön sehen kann, wie man dann mit seinen anderen Midschrechnern in der Statistik nach oben treibt.
Auf welchem Platz weiter denn jetzt gerade?
Wir sind jetzt auf Platz 125 und sind so im Top 200 Feld die einzigen, die fast jeden Tag irgendwie ein bis fünf Plätze nach vorne hüpfen. Also wir sind bis zu 10 Bit, wollen wir in die Top 100. Problem ist, man kann derzeit zwar mitrechnen, aber man kann noch nicht unserem Team joinen, weil die gerade ihren Statistik-Server umschreiben. Man kann aber auch einfach irgendwie seinen Client laufen lassen und einen RC5LCCCDE oder so spenden. Das wäre auch eine Wahrscheinlichkeit. Also falls ihr noch PCs rumstehen habt, die sowieso nichts zu tun haben, dann...
Oder auch PCs, die was zu tun haben. Also es ist ja irgendwie durchaus so, dass die halt irgendwie nur die Rechenzeit dann in Anspruch nehmen, die da auch tatsächlich, die sozusagen frei ist.
Ich habe eigentlich einen PC, der nichts zu tun hat.
Ja, und da ist auch noch ein Macintosh, der glaube ich nichts zu tun hat. Warum rechnest du eigentlich noch nicht mit?
Ich habe einen Macintosh, der nichts zu tun hat, aber ich nicht. Nur einen PC, der nichts zu tun hat.
Was macht denn jetzt der Macintosh gerade?
Das ist ausgescheitert.
Was das für ein Drei-Macintosh ist?
Die benutzt ja nicht alleine. Die sind ja schon alle besetzt.
Ja, da kannst du die kleine Karte aufrechnen.
Na ja, da können die doch jetzt rechnen.
Ja, wenn du mal eine Stromrechnung übernimmst...
Stromrechnung ist doch was Minderes, wenn man irgendwie mitrechnen kann.
Ja, das sage ich dann bei der nächsten Rechnung der BEWAG.
Also nähere Informationen dazu, wenn man da teilnehmen möchte, beziehungsweise auf unseren Webseiten www.ccc.de. Da steht irgendwie auch immer ganz oben, auf welchem Platz wir gerade sind. Und da kann man dann einfach anklicken und sich das irgendwie... Da haben wir glaube ich auch so eine Step-by-Step-Anleitung, wie man das genau zum Laufen bringt.
Genau, Glück hat das schön zusammengefasst. Da kann man sich auch informieren, worum es dabei eigentlich geht. Dass es ja nicht nur Spaß ist, sondern dass man dabei auch beweisen möchte, mit welchem Aufwand bestimmte Schlüssellängen zu knacken sind und wie sicher bestimmte Algorithmen sind. Im gleichen Zusammenhang ist ja zum Beispiel dieser Data-Encryption-Standard, der in den USA nach wie vor Standard ist, die wird mittlerweile in 22 Stunden geknackt von diesem verteilten System. Und bei RC5 geht es halt nicht so schnell.
Soweit das Chaos Radio, ausnahmsweise mal am ersten Mittwoch im Monat. Es gibt Ende März schon die nächste Ausgabe, also am letzten Mittwoch des Märzes, dass es dann nach der CeBIT, vielleicht ein bisschen darüber reden, und dann über Spezialkomputer, also PDAs, Funktelefone, da gibt es ja einiges Neues zu sehen auf der CeBIT.
Und was wir auf der CeBIT so gemacht haben, wie gesagt, wenn ihr auf der CeBIT seid, oder wenn ihr da eh vor habt hinzufahren, dann guckt doch mal, ob ihr euch vielleicht den Dienstag einrichten könnt, und dann guckt dann auch mal auf www.cde. Wir wollen da noch ein bisschen Spaß haben.
Falsch, falsch ja doch hin.
Das war das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club, mit Agent Me an den Decks, mit Live-Musik, die zwar nicht hier jetzt live gemacht wurde, sondern von einem Live-Konzert aufgenommen wurde.
Und mit unserem Lieblingsmoderator, Johnny.
Ach, ist das nett.
Tschüss, es kommt Peter.
Bis dann.
Es kommt Martin.